[Music]
[Music]
yo
brown what's going on it's the lord's
day what's poppin
what's going on akw gerald mack what's
going on d skills h town you milly
rockin how's my levels what's going on
sour piazza what's up
six player what up arc light what up
be lou
bavari
what's going on
talk to me see how these levels are
sounding right quick
also say what's up to the people
what's going on guys
yeah that's what's up that's what's up
talk to me the music is louder than me
[Music]
that's that french
you said cogs are like [ __ ] flex
no doubt
oh yeah now i'm gonna mess with a little
bit more sick yeah it's gonna be a good
day in the realm today lots to talk
about okay matt teach bond i hope i'm
pronouncing that correct first time
checking out the lords here we go
looking forward to it no doubt good
afternoon
[Music]
so we got some fun classic lords day
good topics all that and um maybe some
surprises we'll see let's see how that
go
but um anyway i'm gonna go make sure the
other lords are good i support the king
earlier solve
with him last night
and uh he'll be pulling up as well so
i'm gonna speak to y'all in a minute oh
black conflict x don't crest out
see you
i see you christopher heart i see you we
in here today no doubt
chilling it's gonna be a problem we're
[Music]
hey
[Music]
get you that treat
[Music]
no doubt brother good to see you so look
we're gonna get the rest of my head we
will be back and another fun show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
[Music]
them to be your dog thing very loyal but
i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to
boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger that's
[Music]
imma just chill and watch so many snacks
in the attic i wanted to chill with the
pack and be like a young wolf but then
they would mistake me for addict if i
can imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you gonna be single player
like siren you're gonna get tossed in
the bushes by king david royalty not a
pretender detrimental to an elemental
what's an avatar to a knee bender i
gotta be me though i know it's my
destiny words incognito who cares if you
fly if you steal a mosquito you swear
you ain't something but really
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible other than nothing
is cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle
[Music]
all right hear ye hear ye
and we are live
welcome to the i love podcasts comma llc
and also the lords of gaming.net lord
rufus says say it cog and we are live
all right i got you bro i got you
episode number 232 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's date i'm very
excited well we don't got no special
guests because it's just the lord
we've got forza horizon 5 reviews eldon
ring gameplay xbox and sega strategic
partnership and more g-force leaks now
to discuss so we gonna get right into it
so let's introduce the four horsemen of
gaming those original lords of the realm
here at the round table my codes for the
colemost my brother from another brother
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the heart of the young
wolf my man lord addict how we doing sir
doing pretty good man i got that
eternals i gotta go watch today so i'm a
little bit excited for that yeah yeah
yeah i got got a good show for you guys
lined up got a good show that's what's
up that's what's up man so i saw that
yesterday would you be playing sir
uh
played forza horizon five
uh and i've been playing uh writer's
republic i actually really enjoy
writer's republic someone was because uh
i like the
there's like a like a free road mode
where you can like switch sports and
stuff like drastically yeah i'm not
saying you can't do that in the campaign
but i've never really liked doing
campaigns with that kind of stuff i just
want to go to like the tallest mountain
and go down it
want to talk to romeo or tom or bob like
i don't want to do this this this giant
race because i won't do none of that yo
do that
go and just do what i want to do i ain't
trying out this game tell me what i got
to do you're like why you don't like the
game telling you nothing
[Laughter]
no no no no
fantastic uh forza horizon 5 reviews up
on ilp sir congratulations you put a lot
of work a lot of positive feedback sir
fantastic sir yeah i appreciate the the
chat man you guys showed up man you got
you guys guys was trolling me over my
need for speed love but oh yeah it is
like this he's like why does he keep
mentioning for speed
it's like look i literally brought up in
the beginning of the review the only
thing i can really
compare this to is me playing need for
speed 10 years ago
and then they get mad when i compare it
i literally told you the only comparison
i had was need for speed all i said was
yo where the cop chases that's all i
said
and he said
i can't get into something unless he got
cop chicken
why you got to be ready for the [ __ ] all
the time look it's just look but someone
did a good thing you know it might not
make sense a hundred percent to like the
forza brand but you could definitely put
like a showcase
like you the showcases that forza does
right and you can have that be like like
a [ __ ] chaser why everything guy
cause look man i wasn't alone
i wasn't alone let me ask you a question
is
are you the robber or the criminal
and he's clearly trying to run away from
that are you the police you don't use it
i see what you're doing
horizon i mean we we got a topic about
that but you know it's does it mean you
can't get a little low even though
you're level yeah he's low you come a
little low
i'm coming in low yeah just a little bit
turn it up a little bit turn up a little
bit and turn up just turn on the switch
come in hot
that's pretty much all right i do need
to get back into um
into destiny yeah i'm trying what's
funny is i have
i have like a saying when it comes to
destiny like i will look
and see how many days is left and if i
fill if i fill the day's pressure in me
to get on that then i just
then you know i'll jump on it if i don't
fill them i just keep it moving
man i loaded that game up yesterday i
saw like a hundred and some days on that
thing i turned that right back off i'm
like oh i mean i got your february i'm
good you're like i'm good no no doubt
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer list for the
single-player selfish experience and
also the sastradamus
the lord of clarity and lord patron of
the iron bank bombing better much better
lord sovereign how we doing sir i'm
doing good man i'm chilling i'm i'm a
little under the table right now
my jeans last night
norma jeans are not popping like they
usually yeah yeah yeah they they
definitely neutered they nerfed they
nerfed
we had a good time went to see eternals
with the lord yeah shout out to lord
marlon and lord kaibatsu yes sir chill
out finally take a picture with god
yo i got no pictures with him okay like
i was like i really look at it
it'd be a group pick but i was like i
don't got
i got a few pictures it's all by just
being like even when we went to the the
last stand event it was like yeah we
forgot we just forgot just we got it
yeah so we're making my business to take
pictures with you yeah yeah
i got to do it just in case you passed
away i got paid
ain't nothing worse than somebody
passing away i'm like oh that was my
friend
let's not put that energy out in the
universe with something let's just not
do that right now how is that nothing
worse
not
him not having your picture is diverse
and then the worst thing is okay because
you know it happened to me
yeah all right so
i have healing around yes
yes
right so i got in my wallet you know you
know that little card they give you when
you pass away yeah so to i have it
wrapped around my money right right you
know rick was about his money so i'm
like guard my money boy right so
she's in my wallet right but that's the
only picture i got to my friend and my
my friend was like yo so what did he
look like you know because you were
talking about him i was like you feel
bad yeah
no you're right you're right
that's why i made a conscious not just
for that reason but i made a conscious
effort to have more pictures yes was
solved because i was like we go like
pictures yeah
anyway so
morbid king
king today
lord morbid over here
[Laughter]
you keep it at 100. we just try to
change the energy but continue
yourself
we saw that last night
i didn't watch any combat stuff because
i was busy
blazing narco season narcos mexico
season three start watching the whole
thing um a little disappointed i think
i love all those seasons there's a lot
of action there's a lot of cool story
yeah this one felt like it was like
budget gimped a little bit like they
were just the stories they tried to tell
specifically about the narcos they're
talking about now these guys are some of
like the most
quote unquote revered and kind of famous
so their stories should be more sort of
bombastic yeah and it wasn't it was a
very sort of subdued season
comparison to other ones so right
whatever but i finished it so on to
season four for narcos mexico
um i played forza because i got good
i didn't buy i got the uh whatever the
expansion pack that you get for like 45
bucks or 40 bucks with a game pass
yeah so it allows you access to the game
pass version early so i just played it
uh since yesterday yo
okay okay
oh sorry i do feel like we like i
noticed that there wasn't a topic but i
do feel like we need to talk about that
game pass thing like that well as far as
a lot of people are upset
oh yeah we'll talk about it
they were upset about the the access
that was given yeah and to a point i can
understand or get told but you know that
i do understand what some of these
companies yeah we'll definitely get to
it yeah i think uh being maddie we're
having kids i said they will not like me
later
badge on my chest mm-hmm we know
we continue like you said yeah so that
was it like i'm forza you know i'm
before the head stand for that game and
it's like
that game it's i mean it's more force
you throw it on it's like it's
comfortable you know what you're gonna
get and it's kind of almost in the same
way like it starts the same way
but the polish on this game
like they they threw me into uh quality
mode first right we see what this looks
like quality mode it's fantastic and the
30 feels smooth yeah but when you're so
used to playing 60 just about everything
now yeah no matter how smooth that 30 is
it looks it feels choppy to you just
your eyes yeah your eyes because you see
it now as soon as i switched over to
that 60. oh my god buttery smooth
yo yo yo so yeah that was it um you want
let me read these super chats yeah yeah
please please we move on to king yes sir
uh first we got cedric eight just
welcome cedric h to the realm put the
crest in the chat and he immediately
upgraded to lord silver so shout
it's been a minute since we've seen
subjects yeah
then we got bradwood fight with the
seven dollars i know him
shout out to lord [ __ ] for getting me
back on that crystal d addiction oh see
that see
see you was doing so well
you know before you know we're gonna put
on twitter acting like we're getting
people hooked on drugs
he should have just
because he's the one on twitter that
watches iop and he'll quote tweet things
we said from the lords like in scripture
and then he'll put you a little day like
i like what brad what if i do that
no chris dodo what's hello to you
people keep saying about my volume just
tell me when it's good just tell me when
it's good i'm used to it
yeah lost something maybe just because
you just loaded talking he said you're
not your normal you know boisterous self
that's maybe that's what it is
i don't know so the the rest of this is
that war of a condo is a banger can't
wait to see why that's just dave it does
no war con this bradwood fight still oh
i thought his name was
it was about
my back too
there we go can't wait to see what
crystal d does with joanna dark
right here bradley
then we got game of nominations with the
40 rupee super chat try steering with
the forza horizon 5 the rumble is
amazing yeah i haven't used the steering
wheel no i'm going to know where my man
free r kelly is
this like that's why i got a shout out
christopher at least he still pull up he
comes in he pulled up but it's certain
dudes that you're like where they
actually
[Music]
is not yo you're not doing
that late night late night at king joy
david letterman king joy anyway
there we go tyson lewis with the what is
the chf two dollar super chat i'm gonna
say two thousand i don't wanna see it
jeff is i'll look that up in a minute
what up realm does forza horizon 5 put
any pressure on fable
fable has his own pressure going in
let's talk about it we'll talk about it
we get to uh
i think fable has
probably quadrupled the amount of
pressure that forza would ever have
forced an established brand fable not
only do they have to prove that they can
bring fable back they have to prove that
they can bring fable backs off sure yeah
we got haruki chani two dollars we chat
salute to the lords on this fine sunday
to you as well sir hello salute
then we got oh no it's alex
yeah
salute
i'm expecting my invite in the new year
when i'm done remodeling my house addict
and alex play divinity original sin
monday nights live sub to him
how how long have you been remodeling
your house
[Laughter]
like it's like you've been remodeling
like like just like half an inch a day
absolutely
when he broke down somebody's uh you
know
what it is what it is it's a lot of what
i like about it he plays it both sides
whatever people do something stupid
you're gonna get the smoke so respect to
that but what i like i got a shot about
he doesn't get enough credit is i love
what he's doing on the pc front with pc
ports that xbox really needs to improve
because i'm trying to lead the charge i
want them to improve on that and we be i
mean um alex give it a
keep saying i'm quiet yeah you are a
little quieter is that better yeah
now you're booming now you're booming
now you're peeking but is that better
yes yes yes yes there you go all right
continue
two dollars
why can't we use our xbox avatar that is
true there's no doubt though
real quick chat will you comment on if
you guys can hear me not because because
the chat has a habit you know
besides this time i'm going the entire
podcast then telling us that volume's a
little bit up or down so can you guys
hear me fine now it's almost like you
have to check your zoom setting it
almost feels like something is trying to
suppress you you know what i'm saying so
check it out i'm too loud into that mic
it's like something that's like bringing
it down i just turned it i just turned
it up on the okay so it's all good it's
all good what else we got we got uh one
more smitty smith five dollars we chat
free r kelly is at lamarcus dassa's
house in the twitter space
the book of acts
i know what you're doing sweetie i'll do
it
the man who got them horns five dollar
super chat showing love to you all
worldwide jim hashtag naughty enough
hashtag crystal d hashtag thrown under
the bus y'all with this crystal deer did
it continue
we not gonna have to do
[Music]
i've had a qualifying a long time no no
no doubt
then we got um
gerald mack member for 14 months thank
you my brother gerald mack all hail the
iop salute it's the lord's day keep it
respectful yes
yes keep it respectful respectfully for
sure
then we have matt tykebon right i think
i said it right
five pounds super chat i was at an lg
forza event yesterday and got to chat
with the devs super nice guys but they
were tight-lipped on hordes of horizon
horizon five expansions and fables yeah
okay thank you for trying to ask that
that's that's right
i'll respect it
then we got max the lazy otaku five
dollars
i'm a firm advocate that xbox should
bring back avatar games or make avatars
more useful in games yes pass it with
that baby wear that one versus one
hundred back and then
oh geez that they need to bring that
back i remember that salute to that
yeah let's get one more before we get
kicking yeah there we go i am a dirty
trigger lover two dollar super chat
i gotta get my fix of crystal dmv no no
we need a po time
time for christianity today y'all better
continues
this is what happens this is what
happens
you know they're going to now they're
going to keep doing it i shouldn't even
say that anyway and of course i've been
doing this long enough i know i should
know better
we have the incredible hulk of this aka
the access game act
the prophet of xbox swarming king of the
statues demands nothing less than that
premium experience it is the leader of
the fraud alert movement
b
love it lord k how we doing sir better
than caleb plant yeah
so caleb played it for the floor yeah
man you know uh combat talk with the
king is up sir and i can give you a a
breakdown
of the fight um
we knew who canelo was going in yeah
he's a a 9.8 fighter 9.6 fighter going
into that fight kayla plant was more
like a 8.4 8.5 fighter that was that was
his ea rating
[Laughter]
so when you seen that 99 rate and he was
like
that's that's that barry sanders
that's that you get mad like why are you
always taking canelo son
remember that
um
what we
was going into the fight saying the
people that think that caleb plant can
win
excuse me he was going in and thinking
did the champ lose the step yeah is this
not the champ tonight
any time you're going into a fight
thinking that
the odds is your man ain't gonna win
and if vegas has a crazy odds
vegas knows a little stuff
but um caleb had points in the fight
where he can actually uh took control uh
and
he didn't exercise those options right
uh canelo's indomitable will
pushed him through their fights because
it was moments in a fight where he got a
little bit tired or he got a little bit
of lack of daisical
and he turned it up okay he dug deep and
i said he's the living embodiment of the
mexican pride
at this moment right now like you if
you're saying i'm going by continents
i'm going to pick fighters by continents
when you go to mexico
you're picking canelo there's no mexican
fighter at this moment right now that
embodies that mexican pride as much as
he does and he's earned every last ounce
of it so to to score the the knockout in
the 11th round in the fashion that he
did
with punches that he kept trying to land
the whole fight and a lot of those
punches was missing or was blocked and
he didn't give up on his gamepad that's
indomitable will
that is i'm going to break through at
some point in time and can you handle my
best
no matter if it's the first round or the
12th round no doubt it was the 11th he
gave it to him so you know caleb did his
thing but
it wasn't enough uh you come back champ
and you learn from this yeah uh but
anyway when i was going i was having my
little ginger beer in my head
you a gym was chilling well well jim
sent over a a crate and he said you know
some dude named delroy came to my house
ring the bell why is it dead
yo roy lindo
everyone was like hey man
you said drop this off for you man okay
thank you so much i appreciate it dude
and i pulled out my playstation
controller
blew the dust off it paused um
yo jay barry
that was a beautiful video yes yes i
loved it the way you bend the knees and
you gave them out
you know and then you did let's finish
the fight with the halo
remember that that was nice and he was
doing that
he was here and you thought that you was
going to save face
that wasn't part of the arrangement that
wasn't it you made your bet on this show
live
you had the bravado to be on the show
with your mouth to go against the king
so
you don't get to go in the comfort of
your home in your bathtub
and make a video
thinking you're out of the smoke
smoke is here
this is for you
now
i loved it barry yeah it was fire it was
fire yeah your fans thought he snatched
a victory from defeat
get your butt on
the laps
so that would be uh november the sunday
after the release i mean december the
sunday after release you can come any
day like he could come before it because
you know it's inevitable i'm like thanos
here we go yeah that's right mm-hmm
whatever oh god because i i took um my
vacation next month for
for the video game awards and it starts
in the you know for for ma for halo
infinite and it starts my vacation
starts the day that uh the video game
awards launched oh that's what's up
let me tell you guys if you haven't saw
netflix the harder they fall okay
please go watch it um shout out to uh
executive producer sean carter
nice
sounds whole track is propped yeah oh oh
you said sean carl like what's the
mother dude
that's i was waiting for you to get that
okay probably the best soundtrack that i
heard this year for a movie okay um ill
just alba
zazi
regina king
jonathan mages the keith stanfield
daley roy
[Laughter]
that's just to name a few of the the
cast and i'm gonna tell you right now if
you like the movie tombstone
yes it's like a tombstone mixed with
posse
oh those are classics i remember those
yes ksit feeling it yep christopher hart
feeling it they both say the harder they
for they feeling it thank you
um
the cinematography in that film i'm a
spaghetti western dude i love that stuff
it it hawkens back to the days i'm i'm
shame come back shake it i'm not dude uh
badges we don't need no stinking badges
i'm that
ugly dude yeah um
this movie does all of that
and it does it with style and flair and
it has a twist at the end that you will
not see i don't know i don't care who
you are
you don't see that twist at the end
coming and it made me cry
so i said
god this is amazing you said you watch
it three times you're bad people feeling
it yeah man
yeah one of the best films right now
what i'm playing yeah what you playing
oh
destiny mm-hmm
still
still i pull i pulled down neo on the
best okay i mean not uh yeah damn and um
didn't you go through that phase like a
year ago yeah
so uh you saw me
i guess you saw me the other day playing
it um but i was on playing it and then
did you ever fight did you ever uh uh
finish uh echo generations yes
huh yeah yeah okay i was just like yeah
yeah
you know
yeah
if you didn't if you didn't finish the
king there's a great uh how to on lords
of gaming.
you told me
in the game that i worked my butt off on
and figured out that i could have
cheated my way to the end yeah
and i'm like man why didn't i think of
that attic is probably one of the best
are you talking about just reset the
checkpoints
all right so but i did it the hallway
and it's whatever no doubt um
it's a lot of games that dropped out and
i'm like sporadically going here and
there i'm trying to pay back for blood
i love the game it's so much packed in
the game right that you got to take a
break to figure out okay how are you
going to set up your cards how are you
going to attack this board so that game
is fantastic for me right now so i'm i'm
in between these games playing that
stuff and i was watching that netflix
stuff sold out incredible stuff no doubt
and of course we have to give ninja
himself to shinobi lord cognito
spreading that realness in the roman iop
not telling you what you want to hear
but what you need to hear shout out to
defining dude had some great episodes
this week with mr maddie plays talking a
little bit about that sega thing you
know the topic so check that out should
be up 3.99 a little bit later also um
for the ultimate which was actually
pretty good also check out the last word
had the home team thai guy travis e
bontis good old campfire talk game of
the year talk and some uh destiny
concerns and issues
what did you and travis argue about this
week actually we actually had a very
peaceful fun
or last word care fight it was no
shocking time
because you know then you guys argued
for bonus right
actually
we actually was like yo we are so sick
of talking about trials every week that
it was refreshing to talk about
something else because like every 12 has
been trials
to trial
i think it's less of that you guys just
broke travis he's not trying to argue no
no
he always drivers about that smoke trap
got his gun ready every don't let's
trust me it was a mutual stand down that
we got tired of fighting
i heard they broke trials
in the sense yeah last weekend
because everybody complained now they
got the data this is the last word is up
there we talk about the whole joint is
up there um i'm happy though yeah i'm
happy you know i see a lot of the
tryhards not trying so
hard no doubt
check that out and of course for me man
as far as gaming disco elysium that
thing i was blazing i was trying to get
it done i thought it was a shorter game
and i think maybe because of the fact
that i was really enjoying it and doing
every little side quest that came up
against you know on my screen
man that's some of the best voice acting
in a video game i've ever heard period
it's not even close if you like
detective mystery this is right up your
alley it's dark it's hilarious it's
funny
it's really good a good little twist at
the end too like it was good it was good
the only thing i would say get at it
you're going to finish i have a
statement
the only negative i would see it say is
okay graphically this is not a looker
like that this is some like oil painting
type you know what i'm saying like and
the control need work like i feel it's
really for mouse and keyboard like it's
not like instead of looking at an object
and just go and press it yeah you got to
look at it click and then he walk over
to it type situation you know what i'm
saying so that that's the only thing i
didn't really care for but outside of
that this thing is excellent it is it is
truly
a true hardcore rpg and i think someone
in the chat shout out to obsidian
they're doing some type of detective
dread i would love to see this genre
with a big budget like if they had a big
budget that's why i went that sawyer
game i'm really hyped for that
obsidian's work because i'm hearing that
detective i shot the grub then you see
the joint that's up right now with like
some raccoon or something like that
um raccoons picked on isn't game pass
roughness yeah now um disco legion is
not in game pass there's not a game pass
y'all but that's why i didn't play it
russell
okay with my attention yeah they gotta
get over there it's gonna come it's
probably gonna come i just couldn't wait
but could what's what's gonna say at
it's about to say something so
i i i was when i was streaming forza and
i was streaming
uh writer's republic uh you guys
consistently came in there with this
nonsense about me playing these old ass
games yeah yeah uh so i have decided
i will give you guys the opportunity to
have that happen today all right so i
saw someone buy
i saw someone buy a merchandise so this
is what we're going to do
if uh if there could be five more
merchandises bought by the end of the
show
i will let king decide what game
i like that i like that yo that's what's
up oh shout out to the chat they say
it's a one time thing this isn't me play
that over and over again until i beat it
all right so five merchants i quit it's
over five merchandise all right so they
gotta see the merch it's paid at the top
and also merch is at the bottom on the
youtube look at me like
oh yeah the game is back backbone yeah
the backbone was the game yeah yeah no
doubt no doubt no doubt so that's what i
got but um we gotta let's get the
let me get it to the scribe and then
over do switch outs out there yeah let's
do that let's do that all right so let's
get into it y'all what's up what's up so
look give me one second cause i gotta
get some digs straightened out
oh you get this game oh no you're doing
this yeah we gotta do the scribe we
gotta do the scribe man we gotta do
y'all get the super chats before uh
patreon all right cool so look it's that
time of the month y'all y'all know what
it is that lords of gaming.net
scribe of the month what's up
we don't want these up
i didn't realize all these things would
come up at once yeah i usually just put
one up at a time
right now
so you know it's that time of the month
that lords of gaming.net look man we
have been blessed tremendous tremendous
writer's team and um editorial team i
got to shout them out with uh just
putting out things guys are really
hustling the site is really thriving
more opportunities more fly stuff so um
yeah i'm super excited so you know we
got to celebrate you know someone who
went above and beyond in the month of
october and he's been killing it man
insane work rate timely news pieces he
just did uh some good technical stuff
for geforce now streaming to an xbox
browser also the i think he broke one of
the stories with uh facebook's removing
their account requirement so uh without
further ado
we gotta give it up to the latest winner
of the lord dizzy log that scribe of the
month friend of the realm fellow
instigator my man lord flame aka joe
repco put your hands together for joe
resco what's going on lord playing now
he should have been here hopefully that
um daylight save and then get him thrown
off
but hopefully he can come in here that's
probably what happened that's what i'm
thinking that daylight saving because
almost threw me off so yeah so salute to
him lord flame man he's been putting it
down really great addition to the team
we gotta salute him man he's been
killing it go check out his articles
when you get it matter of fact let me
put this by line in the chat says yeah
let's put the byline in the chat right
quick so y'all can see what my brother
is doing he's really been killing it
with these articles here you go chad
check that out so you can see what's
going on but um yeah scribe of the month
again lord flames salute brother you've
been killing it and uh if you do pop in
let me know we'll let you do your speech
or whatever but hopefully that daylight
saving it and get you too bad but anyway
so if you want to get the uh super chats
and all that
yeah let me get these super chats first
before we pay these other bills we got
it
for what
oh no that's like it this is what is
super funny why is my stuff shout out to
windows 11 because my stuff ain't
scrolling right all right why are you
doing shout out to winners why are you
doing that oh we got
um
before you start attic we got already
two merches shout out to lord starkiller
uh xxx01
bought that classic t with the uh the
unity one the one with the different
colors on it for each console great gear
ilp salute you know what i'm saying this
shout out to
zgll7 he got the banner he wore tapestry
he said good luck at it
so already already have something in
mind yeah two two merchants
i'm gonna do um i'm gonna give it up to
the to the squad to hit me
and um
because
he just threw me under the bus no but
you know what's funny because he don't
want me to pick it he doesn't want me to
pick yeah
i don't know if you i don't know if you
guys watched uh attic show
but someone brought up a game that you
had that you suggested me to play solved
and i brought that game up live and
roasted it
i'll put pong up there for you
we still need three merchandise
i'm gonna give him something
really ridiculous
cause he's a hard gamer yeah
[Music]
all right hold on a second so we got
so first we have donald taco member for
two months shout out six months old hell
the iop thank you sir well hello to you
thank you then we got akw with the five
pound super chat i love my crystal d on
that perfect dark have a great solo
oh hold on merch number three
smitty smith get ready to play tetris
attic playboy bought a classic t
he got that original joy
within the hour he's done yeah he
already got three already and he just
announced it i still i still have hope
there's two
there's two two
we got a long
time lord remember it's pinned at the
top y'all know what to do
it's actually at the bottom too but yeah
good morning lords can't wait to hear
your perspectives on the metaverse and
nft salute to the best of this that's
the conversation that ain't happening
yeah happening oh
number four anonymous brought the pr he
brought the lord together.net in a
unique call he got that purple shout out
shout out to [ __ ] for making that
anonymous purchase no doubt
man
that is not me we got that premium one
more and attic got to play a classic
game of king's choice continue
just one yeah aces said another missed
by
acer
oh he said that's me oh you didn't put
your name ace you got to put your name
in the comment section when you buy it
yeah yeah no doubt no doubt so it's out
there for gay boy daily i want him to
play salute salute
oh it's over and we have a winner so oh
they still buy it shout out to our first
anonymous which probably is asa oh he
got the net gator he got the wolves is
out you know what i'm saying it did
shout out to lord starkiller for number
six because i got to play two oh they
still buy more but a classic tv for
every five i'll do another stream on
that game are you out of control he said
he thinks i'll be game that you're going
to play
listen to this guys
ninja gaiden for the nes oh
let's go
that fire that's a good one for him yes
yes i like that i like that no doubt no
doubt continues on
digital foundry just trashed halo what
then we got max delazio taco ten dollars
to be chat bring back one versus 100
doritos crash course kingdom of keflings
i remember that yes and for why not make
a triple a first party game and build a
stronger connection to your avatar its
own world the great story of the whole
shebang yeah they should they like
avatars
merch chimes are going off in my ears
crazy crazy continue
looking nervous
[Laughter]
that's fun you guys keep putting that
merch i'll keep shooting down these
games
what else i already got to play ninja
gaiden before i was born so you know we
keep going on with
the next one
now next one i'll let [ __ ] pick
last
sovereign's picking one that's fine i
got something for you
let's go
and we got brian lane two dollars which
had great night of fights and a great
day of games yes
then we got brian lane again two dollars
super chat does patreon are joining here
help more either or my brother either is
much appreciated and the very next line
we got brian lanez put the crest in the
chat for brian lane with lord silver
joining the realm somebody hit me up in
my dms and was asking what's that uh
when we're gonna play uh
chivalry two again
[Music]
well we almost had 10. we almost said
yeah because it again
the shout out to demet the medic got a
classic t acg bro he said acg boredom
attic is in trouble
he got the correct oh he got the crest
with the black it's a little acg oh yeah
next alright i got you next i already
that's literally what i was thinking for
him don't you worry i got you dicks
continue oh my god
didn't we
what have i done then we got stitch five
four i'm done i'm done
he pulled four
if he brought four then this is
we want you i want you on that guard
that uh ghouls of ghosts that are all
that ghosts and gobblers
yeah yeah that's the classic right you
put booze and ghosts yeah goes to go oh
you was gonna pick that
no no i was picking rygar
[Music]
not the one from the arcade yes the one
from the nes and yesterday back to the
nes oh my god fire star 66 yo they're
not stopping but the unisex hoodie we
was already going to get this but great
time
[Laughter]
sorry i'm going to wait until they
they're going too crazy i gotta let saw
fish you're going to have to uh to tell
me when saul gets to pick i don't know
does it tell you how many numbers if
everything's been bought um i could go
if i go to the the
table okay
so i've got a second so we got give me
one moment back over here we got um
stitch five dollar super chat uh well
just an fyi i checked my lg c10 vr
output and for some reason forza is
outputting 120 hertz
also is caribbean gym passing by today
hashtag
all right so you might as well just
smitty said he bought three what's your
game yeah yeah just we wasn't exactly we
did we hit the target after solve i'm
closing it no more yes we got it all
three laws so what's your game
we got k got educated i'm gonna do he
said battle told you you don't always
overflow
which one eddie has battled with
the eddies
oh it's over
i want to see controllers throw it at
the screen
i want to see him rage at the devs
all of these going to break him in some
way shape
i can't wait oh this is great
this is great there we go okay so we got
um
then we got spartan ghost two pounds
super chat
uh starfield doesn't know what what it
is when you're out okay
and then we have
don't know taco two dollars with a chap
i just bought two i did it for addie
this this this look i i knew i made the
mistake when i said for every five i
should have just said five in the ends
but yeah it is
because we have to figure out how i'm
going to stream these games next week
uh probably the week after next i will
stream whatever the first one is i'll
probably put a chat a poll in the chat
and see which ones i play first yeah
we'll we'll rank them yeah but i said i
said you have to go no i said you picked
the first one i just say i stream
yourself
oh
come on but let's give let's get it
could be such a community showed up i'm
going to give you a community let's put
the polls
put the poll in and say
out of the three right which one they
want to see first out of the ghouls and
goals the ninja gaiden and what was the
third one on battle toes i'm just
playing
but you got to put nes yeah yes yeah
shout out to assemble what's going on
bro i see you
here we got donald taco again five
dollars which had the difficult game
conqueror about to get conquered by
ninja gaiden nes no doubt no doubt
that we have lord stark killer xbox
series excellent one member for two
months how about ninja gaiden on xbox
for lord addict
i've given play that the original ninja
gaiden what the original knit the
original uh 3d ninja gaiden on xbox
think
yeah so i'm gonna say it's uh what's the
first one is it go is ghouls of ghosts
is the first one right or it's ghost of
goblins ghosts and goblins is the old
one ghouls and ghost is the one for for
genesis which is price it's just as
difficult
as well give them that one you're like
the genesis one yeah
the one with the armor
isn't that the snes
we don't need to talk about
that yeah we we we gotta finish what you
gotta figure out your sentence
super graphics
yeah we got to see what's available that
he can yeah we also got to see what's
available they could stream on console
because we have to use um maybe if you
switch on the virtual console i would i
would have went with super ghouls and
goals me personally the nintendo one was
fantastic but okay
there the pose in the chest yeah put the
part all right cool chat y'all know what
to do which one of those y'all want to
see first the attic
and shoot with the flame that pulled up
you know what i'm saying but we get the
super chats then we'll take care of
flight we got you bro
all right the king is winning
there we have that we have near mental
10 super chat neo what's up
my apologies for strolling in late what
are we doing make sure you tell will me
so he can buy all the merch
yo wake somebody wake will be up
somebody wake will be
finished it's closed
it's not it's close
i don't care if he comes and buys that
whole story
somebody else somebody get will get debo
on the phone
let's go if it was a tattoo then i'll be
fighting for it but
wake up good game behind the box
shut up
yo let me tell you something i watched
these dudes take the hot chip challenge
and i'm i'm i'm a legend yeah no you are
you're for sure for sure
how you survived that
kofi shout out to kofi over there on
press start he did some spicy noodle
stuff and he's thinking about cancelling
the hot chip challenge because of it
oh no
i'm gonna i will honestly tell anybody
that things about that
don't go down
yeah yeah
can kill that right there um
so he says also i want to congratulate
my man cog aka eric adams on his new
york city mayoral win
shout out to hip hop gamer having an
interview with eric adams yes hello
hello hello
then we got hold on a second
this poll hold on how do we get the pole
to jump out of the way because it's in
my way right you just hit it you just
hit it yeah you just click on it and
then it'll like pop up after you put it
you know
it's not no you just like press in the
middle on the top like in the middle of
it on the top and it will it'll like
scroll yeah like oh there there goes
there you vote for me
it's like it's like politicians you know
every lower voter for himself
let me got somebody smith
i cop three shirts then he got cute
two dollars
it's a me
it's a bee a flame
oh we caught up
yeah we're going all right flay so let's
give flame the proper giant man because
yes
you should you should thank me because
of that nonsense i started gave you a
little bit of time to come here and get
your flowers
listen man it is that time watch you get
tortured
brother we gave you your roses man
tremendous monthly gaming.net your first
scribe of the month you've been killing
it the volume the work rate has been
absolutely insane love what you did i
talked about the technical aspects you
did with the geforce now article as well
as um also the i believe the facebook
account article you've been killing it
man so little speech talk to the people
i thought i was here just reading the
manscape dad
yo you didn't get it
listen
we didn't get that bag yet all right
we're gonna get that bag it'll be
talking about future bags
i can't wait i can't wait till i can
read that yeah we need songs to read a
manscape and that's when you know we
made it
with the suave voiceover yes for that
last year yes so with this man
what's going on man play talking what's
good
it was good man um
like
for like last uh was it i've been here
for got like five months or so yeah i
like seeing everybody that's been
joining in like getting scared of the
month i was like i gotta set my game up
you know people like sean the sheriff
yeah chris jones hello everybody like
they've been killing it i i
like i gotta
i gotta start my game up
they've said they're awesome so
absolutely salute to you brother you've
been killing it and again insane work
greg you're always eager to jump in help
out on the team everyone's giving
positive feedback it was pretty much
unanimous this month for you and uh like
to see your journey ever since you came
over and salute to you and the team but
uh looking forward to more things no
more instigating king in the super chat
sir oh
hey
i don't i don't join in
early enough to be able to do that
anymore
you guys knock me out like two hours
ahead
no doubt man but i appreciate you coming
through make sure you hit up solve if
you have not hit up soft already oh yeah
that that is in route oh okay okay so
already got my man take care i'm tripped
out with some okay that's what's up bad
brother i appreciate you thank you so
much brother ridiculous yeah i
appreciate you brother
keep up the good work man fantastic
addition to the team
appreciate y'all and it's nice meeting
you everybody no doubt it's a great day
brother
have a good one bro
bye no doubt no doubt the amount of
margins yeah should we go after chat
read but for days
continue yourself
uh then we got spartan ghost two pound
super chat y'all always be making attic
sweat in here
i am i ain't gonna lie i'm sweating
i'm sweating a little bit man i am
sweating a little bit
i mean i miss
yeah i know but it's just going to be
full stream i'm going to stream all
those games for about two and a half to
three hours each since you guys did
okay let's go let's go but but after
that yeah we we we'll talk about like an
encore after i stream after i go mental
from these games
there we got a
member for four months lord bronk bunty
anybody that watches us that does any
kind of voice over man then you need
someone solved yo
if y'all looking for good voiceover my
man is nice man like y'all need to get
my man a bag like he read super chats
like this
you guys need a super chat reader yeah
so we all called up baby yes sir wait
let's get this uh patreon let's get back
to the community yeah sir it's time to
pay the bills you know what time it is
that time of the month to pay the bills
and say thank you and give back
so here we go we have
that ten dollar gift card giveaway
coming up first
and the winner is
i only have the government so i'm gonna
read the government and put them on
frustrated
salute he's out there
no doubt no doubt so thank you very much
uh our 10 our 20 gift card giveaway
now goes to
small print tv
you don't want no laundry you go to my
base small print tv baby he got you
salute salute salute to him not me the
pawns is crazy
that we have hold on a second our
teespring giveaway okay we'll get the
trip
and that goes to
brandon bryce okay yeah brandon bryce
[Laughter]
that's it we are good we're good on our
on the
on the grip for this month uh once again
as always thank you guys
every single month our membership grows
like it's really crazy the amount of
love and support you guys show us either
here on patreon or in youtube you guys
are amazing like
we would have never thought this year
even a year ago it's like
it's crazy so thank you so much and just
hit me up in dms i think i've taken care
of everyone i think by this time so uh
just hit me up and let me know what you
need and i got you no doubt no doubt so
let us get into
oh actually no i got work to do because
there was more swag that had to be read
so sorry about that
yo shout out to ac
yo his name why his name is that shout
out to the legendary acg what up brother
got it
in trouble buddy
a shout out to carrick oh man let's go
let's go let's go acg what's up how are
you doing man i just can't wait to see
him lose his mind
did you see your selections
oh dude i i had my own for like shadow
of the beast and wrath
and then you guys were hammering him
with these really hard ones
out of that
it's too that's too raw
you know what acg since there's so many
but i'll let you pick one
oh seriously i i i am a huge fan of
ghosts and goblins yes
whatever you know i know there was some
name question i can't remember exactly
i'm a genesis free do we freeze
on youtube
it is an incredible game amazing
soundtrack it is it is it you will might
you might you know go through it just
because of how good it is but first i
got to give a couple shout outs okay
number one king
i found it which is the that's the
ubisoft the uh
do you have that one the watchdogs one
that thing is
sweet and i guess they gave it to me and
because it's you know like merch i hit
it
oh because i knew i was coming on and
then sovereign uh yeah
bobble is awesome thank you very much
like that poker smash a couple others
are awesome and i also have to give a
shout out to addict he jumped into our
discord to play uh back for blood
and i've never seen a group
pull failure from success so often
it was so bad and i i just want to give
a shout out to his positivity because he
just hung in there and we got smoked
again and again
again
actually gave me that classic just leave
me i was like no everyone's going home
yeah yeah i'd be down and i'm like just
go just go man and he's like ah
everybody's safe we don't leave a man
behind
how are y'all doing that were you
playing on
oh dude what what what difficulty yeah
bro we were on uh normal like normal and
we were getting into
yeah dude or normal then this game is
crazy
oh this is pre-patch by the way too okay
but we were playing and we would get uh
to a certain point and then you know and
it was all random it's not randoms but
friends like nobody played together but
uh it was just having a good time and
then you know it was it was it was
awesome so shout out to shout out to him
for showing up and continuing through
the loss he's like a colts fan
past special duo right
yeah
thanks for pulling up brother and of
course we got another legend of the
realm new york's finest vx in the
building that's the legendary ever born
saga what's going on bro how you doing
man
i don't know what's happening how's
everybody a little low brother turn up
turn up a little bit turn it up a little
bit let me fix this
working on a lot of big things too man
oh yes he is yeah he's working on a lot
of [ __ ]
all right let me let me try to fix this
i got to go into the audio yeah yeah
just check your zoom settings make sure
that volume up a little bit you know
what i'm saying
i got to fix my camera
there we go but salute to you brother
and uh you got something that you may
want to talk to the people should i just
should i just do the rick
hit the music
i think you should i think you should
hit the music hit the music
[Music]
[Music]
mike you're back
addict we got to get you going sure
what's going on in this man's screen man
it's not uh you're not sharing i'm not
seeing it
it says that you're sharing your screen
all right let me know if y'all see it
because i don't i see it it's really
small it's really good i see it at the
bottom yeah yeah it's not like full
screen sharing
it's like sharing a thumbnail
there we go there we go there we go no
doubt so talk to the people everybody
what is going on what are you doing
what's happening
so so so um you guys know i did a
kickstarter earlier in the year and we
launched uh ariel's adventure yes right
but uh the thing about the everborn saga
it is it is sort of uh one story
that takes place in two different
timelines but there's four series and
each of them follows a different
character
telling the story from their vantage
point no doubt i got kicked out of the
chat for y'all so they can so they could
know what's going on
by the way by the way just for this show
what's up the kickstarter is live right
now oh we launched it right right now
for ilp it's all right
but um so so four four different
characters now you've already seen
prince of arcadia because we're four
chapters into that we just launched
ariel's adventure now this is the third
of the four series this is the redlands
and it takes place on the east of
arcadia where prince of arcadia takes
place in ethan where ariel's adventure
takes place this is all the way east
this is where the colored folks live
because i was wondering where we were in
your universe
so
so while while all those guys are
fighting in arcadia there's a whole
other part of the world
that um they don't travel too much and
there's there's history there to it but
uh the character the main character that
we follow is karma she is a bandit you
can see uh escaping in the front horse
right there uh so so she leads a crew
and they basically rob from the royals
give it to the commoners what was that
what's the dudes with the twitter i was
trying to find one
they look real fast right there
i'll get to her in a second she that's
karma right so so
uh by night she's abandoned like i said
they rob from the royals and give to the
commoners they really don't like the
royals because they kind of neglect the
commoners you know you know how that is
right
right um but the secret is that she is
one of the royals now she is a princess
by day
yeah
moonlighting right
but she by day she
we did we'd be like to narrate a comic
with king
eating down low eating cornbread in the
middle of the day
she masqueraded a nice soft bed four
quarters
and then she goes back up to the satin
sheets
and then
[Music]
but um so the the king who is sitting on
the throne now killed her parents to get
on the throne but he raised her like his
own daughter so she is he did the
ballina
katana
right
she's leading her crew to systematically
target his allies so she can weaken him
so that she can get her revenge back
both right
exactly
but she can't tell the king that she's
robbing his friends and she can't tell
her friends that she's one of the royals
because when you think about it she's
using them as pawns which is exactly why
they hate the roy got you right so she
has this whole double life going on
and and and you know this all connects
back to the main saga because that's her
personal drama but in between that she's
having these nightmares but those
nightmares she's a liar
are actually visions of the future
yo senpai country say yo y'all need to
do story time with kids
this would be lit yeah we would actually
do well like have king acg and just
narrate
what's up man if i do an audio book for
this i'm getting killed
stop it i'm conflicted i'm having
nightmares i'm taking my friends and i'm
lying to them while i'm lying to the guy
who stole me while she's saying this and
she's in her bed with a belly all
distended from eating cornbread
you're
she tells her friends she's like you can
have my cornbread
we just
[Laughter]
why is the cornbread the rich people
food
[Laughter]
clearly you just realize that that's
true
like she's the criminal mastermind but
she's just telling the guard to go away
everyone get your balls off before we
lose control
she's having these visions of the future
where she is seeing magnus the everborn
because we named the whole series after
the bad guy right and ariel from ariel's
adventure keeps showing up in her dreams
so they will link up later not in this
book because this whole everything with
everyone is character focused right so
before we get to the larger narrative we
want to have interesting characters day
one that's why our
our intro issues are real character
focus as opposed to just dropping lore
on you all the time and and then the
lore will will seep in sort of naturally
as the as the story plays out and it all
builds to this big crescendo of a war
of the sarahs versus the paladins but
this is the new one and i just a little
bit of the tears i want to tell you guys
about if you supported the first
kickstarter yes and you got all the
books i made a tier called loyalty that
is just for you guys
so with that
it will give you this it will give you a
hard cover
of um uh prince of arcadia ultimate
edition book two which has chapters
three and four and they're fully
remastered with 20 pages of bonus
content and you will get uh a custom uh
t-shirt and poster with that one so so
that that's the one to go for and then
if you're if you're new to the whole
thing just go straight to the rightful
air
that one gives you all the books we've
ever done plus the posters and t-shirt
and all the digital stuff and the last
thing i want to tell you guys about is
the ever born tier which allows you to
become a character in the series
[Music]
that one is limited there's only 10
people that can get that right i want to
be her brother
messed up right
and we're going to talk about them
dude so it's live right now brother
right it's live right now four four iop
we we put it on
and and we're just trying to make this
happen this is the third of the fourth
and then we will have all four series
and they will all continue and they're
all meant to be sort of red at the same
time so
salute to you brother i love what you're
doing the art style the quality the
writing it's been fantastic and then one
thing you honor everything you do
because like one thing i got to respect
you like everything comes on time i got
my books you know what these guys are
like all that man so it's a little
support i put it in the chat you know i
mean the new season is out to everybody
saga the badlands incorporating all that
but
potatoes don't have
uh disrespecting cornbread that is
[Laughter]
how long how long have you been doing
this
i've been so the books i've been doing
for
three
three years now maybe three and a half
years but everborn has been a thing for
almost a decade because it was a video
game at first i released a
2d platform on on windows phone uh i
don't know if you remember that
and then i started working on a sequel
and then i wanted it to have a story so
i um
i just started writing notes notes
became maps maps had kingdoms kingdoms
characters characters backstory and now
we're like six chapters into this uh
epic fantasy that do you think you can
do me a favor and and um tweet me and
i'll get you on the podcast the ac oh
yeah
we have a creator podcast where we have
we've done kickstarters multiple times i
did my own and then other people come on
and we talk about the process and and
get
i'll dm you and you yeah please do
please do it yeah you know what you also
need to do everyone you need to do a lot
more content like of what it's like to
create a universe yeah i don't think
behind the scenes is huge yeah it's a
lot eat that up yeah that's a lot
brother it's not been very cool i've
been trying to get into more of that on
the everborn saga oh by the way i'm ever
born saga everywhere that's uh
playstation xbox steam youtube twitter
instagram tick tock all those things
awesome you type in everyone sago or
everbornsaga.com you will find me but
yes i've been wanting to do more of that
because we do that on the real show me
and k asante hello we try to do it uh
every thursday and we kind of talk about
this kind of stuff comic book movies and
tv shows and things like that we just
did a dune review which was uh pretty
fun which got a little bit heated
because uh it's a lot of dune apologists
out there
we can talk about that another time
and also we got a shout out to brother
boom for a lot of people my first time
and a lot of people's first time even
hearing about you with from tom gaming
mr boom sick excellent you don't say
double viral gaming youtube channel
salute to him and all that but we got a
lot of show to get into but i had to get
your balls off man it's a little tricky
fantastic man it really does for luke so
let's get into it on poll results are in
people have spoken to the question with
sony's recent formation of the
playstation pc llc do you think the
company's recent aggressiveness with pc
ports is devaluing the playstation brand
the winner at 50 percent of the votes so
fairly close was the messy lords i don't
care we all told y'all worldwide jim is
not for play play
coming in at second place at 40 percent
of the vote was no this model is pro-ip
and financially helps the brand sell
more better long-term games for sony and
in last place with only nine percent of
the vote was yes last playstation
consoles get sold on this model games
are devalued if pc ports are in close
proximity day and date to ps5 release
date so uh shout out to everybody who
participated lord now
wait where's every time no no
no i get nervous with king takes the
camera off because i'm just about to ask
him how he feels but i don't know if
we're getting a caviar what upstairs to
get something is he putting a costume on
i don't know what's going on because my
kid camera disappeared i get nervous but
let's ask us
let's ask you man the the realm says
worldwide jim's not for play play man
what you're feeling look man i keep
getting attacked because i said it does
devalue the console but you know that
they be acting like i'm sitting there
saying you don't need a reason to buy a
playstation like i never said that it
was like it doesn't really value the
console not for the either the pc for
the no not not the brand the console but
and it don't it doesn't devalue it on
everyone either it only devours it on
the people that have a pc and
playstation they know exactly what
why they a
devalues what value
who values what value and what value is
value
it does not devalue anything
i told you i'm worldwide
[Laughter]
just jim i got a question jim
we got you in the realm
uh so what is the mindset that if you
have a pc and you've been buying a
playstation just for the exclusives and
you bring their stuff to pc day and date
how would that not devalue to that
particular type of game
why would it devalue them
that's why i'm asking you upstairs right
so if your pc downstairs you play it on
your pc downstairs
you have your playstation upstairs you
play it upstairs i'm giving you options
well what if they don't want to play on
please because you know a lot of people
are resisting sometimes they're
dominance maximus aurelia spencer has
already told you you want to play on pc
i'm following his lead man oh it's the
world what did you hear
did you hear the news what's new sir
hill dominus maximus are really
expensive as a 75 foot yacht
is a 75 foot yacht a thing isn't it
just a boat
[Applause]
foot up
man you guys need to purchase every last
thing that i put on pc
don't listen to attic talking this mess
and this scrum scrum stuff
that's what you're supposed to be doing
all right he's trying to deflect from
the situation uh-huh
god it was coming in january
[Laughter]
i wasn't ready for that warrior oh my
god and we'll talk about more later
listen king got to come back down here i
got to go
thank you again absolute pleasure to to
have you know
jamaican jim ryan pull up
jimmy cliff man jimmy clinton
jimmy jimmy cliff jimmy cliff you know
we're so blessed to have this direct
connection he should have had like smoke
filter behind him but he's just smoking
as much right like the 3d with the 3d
filter
yes yes actually we need to watch
predator 2 and yeah that guy from
predator 2. man one of you the jamaican
from president that was awesome
i feel the vision man addict you are up
man we got a lot to talk about
uh force on horizon five man let me
actually get you know what i just forgot
i had a question for the jamaican gym
come back to it you get back to you get
back to it all right let's get the super
chats first you're right correct me yeah
let me get this there we go
we'll go on a second so we have
dustin goings five dollar super chat
just got the backpack best gaming
podcast around keep it up thank you
brother
then we got ksanti 10 super chat
salute to lords on this fine sunday
shout out to my sometimes slanderous
homie mr everborn saga out here turning
dreams into action
all the time slanderous always always
head to kickstarter to help make this
another successful campaign yeah the
kickstarter link is there in the chat
then we got smitty smith five dollars
which had shout out to everborn saga i'm
getting ready for that redland salute
the book of acts
then we got black ronin five dollar
super chat ever born saga i'm trying to
be in the story as the bull who smashes
the jaw and dips out after one night
no doubt then we have matt tyke bond
with the 10 pound super chat oh no it's
alex went into this the amount of pc
players who own the ps4 ps5 is so small
there's only about a 25 percent overlap
so it's just selling more games to more
people who couldn't play them before
yeah exactly good point
when when when uh worldwide jim comes
back
ask him to what happened to all of those
uh gaming pcs
that people said that they had
other people were releasing games on pc
they were in the cloud they were in the
clouds
they were playing they were playing
shadow that's what they're playing
you're ridiculous
all right cool let me get the merch
because i still have some version to
catch up then i'll give it to addicts
wow yeah sorry just just a few oh kay
asante with the classic t he said he's
planning on buying the classic t anyway
but to help educate lord youngblood at
it on these nukes some of these games
i'm in and then we got anonymous i
bought a classic pullover hoodie salute
somebody got the backpack salute
anonymous neo mental with the snapback
he puts kid icarus question mark that
were kidding us
yes
icarus from eternals yes yes sir bry
lane got the classic teeth thanks for
the hard work ilp and cls all salutes a
little much love brian lane and then uh
we got phoenix down three one eight
classic clover hoodie with the gray love
the pod always look forward to spending
sunday with the lord salute david hot
right got that pint glass happy lord's
day let's get solved this manscaped wow
you wrote that bad skateboard he was
solving to read it in the sultry smooth
voice i'm sorry
basically so look now we are caught up
and i think we're going to warn you and
then we got to get the show we got to
get you lenders two dollars super chat
stop calling him jamaican gym respect
is what it is so look lord addict you
are up one of the highest rated games
likes going on right now forza horizon 5
the reviews are out yourself had a
fantastic review up on ilp la la la a
lot of positive feedback so just real
quick man your thoughts and you know
before we pass it to the round table
because you would abandon the hour right
now what's your thoughts on this thing
man
i actually enjoyed it like look i am not
as a racing person still uh you know
uh the the game what i can enjoy from it
is it looked really nice uh i i
one thing that i didn't bring up in the
review that i forgot to because i had it
written down i don't know what happened
besides it even speed continue
your people were really roasting yeah
yeah but it's okay man it's okay because
i like i stated i said that was the only
casual game of racing i know about but
anyway we're not gonna go into that it's
like there's so much breakable stuff in
here sometimes i feel like because of
those older games i played i could just
slide into a rail just to like stay on
the map and then
i'll be doing it on like a bridge and
then i go off the bridge
so it was a it's it's a nice little
thing i i do think it's it's uh you know
it's definitely worth playing uh you
know i see a lot of
a lot of talk in the industry now
especially from like far cry uh
six that came out that's like you know
it's just more forza more far cry and
like to a point i understand i feel like
there are improvements they can make
into it but
you know i personally feel like because
of the
the positive reception that playground's
always gotten with
forza they came out
with already a game above its time from
the start gotcha so you know i'm not
gonna say they can't approve it i'm not
gonna say they can't
that they can't not improve it i'm just
saying that's like look from my
perspective to someone that don't play
and keep in mind like i don't have this
this fatigue because i didn't play forza
horizon five right so much i didn't play
three so i'm not coming into this like
it's more four is it like to me when it
comes to games like this it's like look
like
every game every franchise i feel like a
lot of the core is always the same right
stuff they change around it that makes
it different and it's like look like i
feel like one of the biggest things that
i think they can improve on is like a
better form of narrative campaign that
you do in the festival gotcha but you
know i don't have but the thing is like
i don't want to like really state too
much because i don't play racing games
yeah you are
like
i don't want to to make statements like
that and then be like you know it
because i saw what happened to final
fantasy you know i love that franchise i
still love the franchise but i do feel
like it's it took a downhill because
chasing the bag trying to open it up
more
took away from the
kind of final fantasy that i like
playing okay so it's like when people
was like oh this is what they knew
that's what they need to do i'm gonna
let racers say what that game needs to
do i feel like because i'm gonna keep my
mouth shut
i would respect respect let's get on
acgme man because obviously again you
also had a fantastic review got a chance
to check out some of that man and just
just hearing you know you had a lot of
every laugh about even if you're not
using the convertible it's one of those
hair blowback type games yeah
so what's your feeling man now that
you've reviewed it and stuff like that
what's your feeling overall on forza i
mean lord's actually right like he i
mean just because he
hasn't played a lot of racing games some
of the stuff that he mentioned is i mean
it's all we talked a little bit prior to
him doing it and we're bouncing some
things off each other but i will say
this people who want um forza horizon to
change the iteration was already between
forza motorsport and forza
that switch was already done and it's
not going to suddenly become a shooter
overnight i don't know exactly what
people are expecting like are we
expecting a forza horizon fps of course
not so the improvements that they do
still need to be within the arcade
demographic versus the racing hardcore
simulation demographic which i think is
already
attempting to be done by forza
motorsport so what i saw in this game
was probably their pinnacle and what i
mean by that is and i didn't say this in
the review because i think that's more
of a not a political but that's it's a
softer discussion is that from now on
there will be more heat on them so do
they do the japan thing which i think a
lot of fans are like don't leave forza
motors or don't leave horizon before
doing japan like i think a lot of people
would like that but what you have is a
title that did change a bunch of stuff
it fixed the prologue the prologue for
the original or for the last game by the
way i've played them all and i don't
have fatigue the fatigue thing when
somebody comes to me and says they're
tired
they're tired
that's it it doesn't indicate anything
about the game that to me is not the
same thing because new people are born
every day because luckily we all have
sex every day
salute to the appropriation process yeah
yeah shout out to appropriate
the thing is though is i had somebody
telling me you know hey you haven't
played an rpg unless you played the
original final fantasy vii speaking of
what lord addicts said and i'm like dude
people weren't even born what are you
talking about these people getting in
get to have an amazing game on game pass
it is fantastic it's probably the
pinnacle which means they will need to
do big jump in cars something like that
i agree with that i agree with addict
that the story
could be better but here's the thing
attic didn't go hard enough on one thing
and i i told him i'm going to help him
i'm going to like write some critiques
on his review he had three openings for
the review which was hilarious
i could tell he was so nervous about
like what do you say but here's the
thing he didn't go hard enough let's go
forza horizon tries to pretend they
don't care about customization of your
character but they put the effort
everywhere your character shows up blank
eyed staring into the depths of the
abyss
they look like mannequins and then you
look like you shop at the world's worst
hipster store
and i talked about that in my review
it's bad i mean and by the way is mexico
george central because everybody's
wearing jords i've never seen a pair of
jorts
since miami vice tv show
everybody's wearing jorts and they show
up and they've got bad hairdos they've
got bad because people might say who
cares but the thing is
they care obviously yes what i would
like them to do is if they're gonna have
customization yes um really go nuts on
it because i can win a shirt that's
seven thousand dollars by the way seven
thousand dollars but i can't sell it
and that can take the spot of a spin for
a car and you can't tell me that
somebody's not gonna look at that and
say wait yeah i just wasted a spin and i
got a pair of jorts for seventeen
thousand dollars i can't tell back
you know what's worse icg when there's
like a horn and then a shirt and like a
really bad car that you want and it's
like and it goes it does that thing
where it's like
like it's a las vegas you know burn slot
where it's fake large story just cut
this short it's a it's an incredible
racer yeah it is just like gears the
last gears in the way that it runs
performance-wise is is unbelievable
and it run yeah and i know that there's
issues here and there there will be with
every game but that game
does
stuff that is just
incredible graphically and it's all an
open world you can drive anywhere it's
just we're there man yeah playground
playground definitely starting out here
match and that's the fable engine yeah
just so you know
i said if things are looking like that i
got no problem
because i got moved
man let's get to you brother did you get
a chance to get it or have you been
paying attention to this oh no no no i'm
not i will play that on the official day
today oh
now here's the thing just two of the
points that you made jeremy um firstly i
am
uh i am kind of um
disappointed in forza horizon 5 because
i wanted it to be cogs just one i wanted
to be a third person
you pull it beside them and it has like
a
and i wanted the driver to have like um
child issues so they'd be like a dad
you know what i mean said that
he's crying shoulder sobs you know where
he's like that is how you evolve the
[Music]
are you implying for this game to be
great it has to follow this template
saying that's the only way it would win
game of the year
speaking of which you're gonna like my
follow-up question to the panel y'all
gonna love it continue though
but now on a more serious note
i've i've been coming around to this
recently
and uh the most egregious uh offender in
my opinion was the ascent now i know
it's a small team so i don't want to
give them too much uh crap for it but it
is emblematic of a larger problem
i
am actually
uh
very seriously coming of the opinion
that we should just get rid of character
creators and games i think they should
spend money and create interesting
looking characters you'd create four or
five of them uh spend the money on the
the development effort and design time
on interesting character designs giving
you four or five to pick from and that's
it no way why fraud are not another one
no no go ahead tell me i'm wrong i want
the ball headed dude that they ain't
gonna make so i wanna make
[Music]
you all over the place
[Laughter]
this is going left you ain't got no hair
they got a bald head you are actually
you you know what they do
they say you know what you're gonna get
a guy just like this and then you your
face is in every room like you'll make
him and put him in every game
the template going in and you can't say
it's not true because when we went to
play um what was that game state of the
cake
mm-hmm oh you're talking about oh
everything is outside
[Laughter]
skin tone sovereign where you can't pick
the right one it's like where's pasty
but slightly exactly
summertime where's that guy here
you know what though i i agree with king
on this and i tell you why why because
sometimes i i understand ever born's
point where like look focus on making a
great character right
just real quick so do you think maybe
his uh you know everboys point of view
go towards more like extremely narrated
games where they try to give you
customization no i think type of games i
think sometimes when you create like
even in like an open world game or
whatever right if you give me a
character that's well that's well that's
created it has a great backstory great
voice acting whatever you're going to
resonate with that character and i get
that right as opposed to this like blank
avatar that you sort of project yourself
onto but beyond that there's not a lot
of personality right i know we've had
games like that where they do have a
voice actor that's a specific you know
it's a specific sort of performance and
you and and you put your face on it
right right and my baker is troy baker
and a troy baker show yeah exactly there
you go
well my thing is this like sometimes you
have to count on
you have to count on the devs getting
representation right and you know
we're moving towards that but there are
still instances where they kind of get
halfway there right
let me let me finish this
the last thing that i saw that was like
almost there
was miles morales and i say almost
because of this
the representation of new york culture
and the representation of puerto rican
culture particularly at the holidays
yeah it was fantastic beautiful
fantastic yeah
miles himself
was not as a character
was not in a lot of ways but
specifically for me
the voice acting i thought the voice
actor associated with him
i felt in a lot of ways he was like a
simple kind of like i wasn't a fan
and i'm just like why does he sound
like like he he sounds like he was not
raised in new york city like he just
sounds like he wasn't or he got beat up
a lot right he got beat up a lot and for
me it was like okay you oh you're almost
there you're almost there what i want
if you're gonna go ever born drought
right you have to like re i i want to
see
somebody that rese that resembles and
acts like me i want to see somebody that
resembles and acts like king and cog
because that's where we come from right
so they
both
both arguments are valid
i just don't know how long it takes us
to get to wherever born so i want to
give it back
yeah i want to speak to that point
though there was a uh uh spaces the
other day uh productive spaces like this
that is this oh wow wow
you're looking for thank you
to haystacks for you um but they were
talking it was about representation in
video games
and one of the points that i made there
which i will make here it's a larger
audience i hope this echoes out now you
could um
you know i
there was someone on that spaces that
talked about they saw miles morales
and it brought a tear to their eye just
to see
themselves represented in that right in
a video game
and and that's great however
how starving do we have to be yeah right
right just seeing miles morales
represented in the way they represented
him brings a tear to your eye right
that's a bigger picture yeah yeah that's
who you go
as as long as we are asking someone to
represent us properly it'll never be
done and so you we have to go more of us
have to remove and i know that there are
uh artificial things but i'm talk i'm
only talking about what we can control
which is us right we have to remove some
of the glass ceilings we put our our on
ourselves and we have to create the
things that we want to see we have to be
the change that we want to see in the
world and and and we've seen this with
uh ariel knights never yield yeah right
that we oh yes luke him salute i was so
happy to have him on right yeah
and the developers of cana i think those
are those yeah
right so so it's not like we have to
have low quality stuff that's part of
the reason why i began to make this
whole everborn thing so that
i i can't complain about uh someone else
not representing me probably if i'm not
trying to represent myself so i want i
want uh us to
you know create we all have stories to
tell
we all can do these things we love this
industry let's more try to be a part of
it and if they don't want to let you in
their door then you build your own house
yeah and then and then you know that
is completely valid right but the tear
to the eye for miles morales and every
hispanic person actually saw christmas
and
being represented in that way walking in
the street doing the salsa dancing
hearing the music here and everything
exactly
it was actually phenomenal right we got
to start somewhere right that's what i
was going to add was that it's the first
of miles and so my opinion is that's a
good
it's like a great start it's a good
start i don't want to be the one saying
that but i do i'm all for kina like i
learned more about that that is awesome
to me and i know that there's jackasses
in the world [ __ ] them though excuse me
[Laughter]
that's i love what atg
you gotta look at it at this part right
that sparks something
you know it has to spark something your
words also resonate with individuals
that are trying and you know you sit
down with acg and y'all do the
background on how to the how to part but
that spark has to start from that kid
seeing himself being represented it's
it's
you know we have been marginalized in a
lot of spaces right i'm no pun intended
yo
that was bar that was bars
marginalized in a lot of spaces
but
to to get past that you have to see
some people are visual a lot of men are
visual yeah right so in doing so and i'm
just talking about men in general but
i'm just talking about the little you
know kid who saw himself and the tear
came in his eye or the grown man who
went a whole lifetime without seeing
that and you thought that peter parker
was going to come save the day no there
was no peter parker you are spiderman
right and we're going to handle that in
this manner so
we're starting to see that
representation take fruit
from people spark that spark so i don't
want to say it was a small thing right
it was a larger thing but what you're
saying is even a greater thing so let me
ask you let me ask you real quick king
like do you think because of the
magnitude of of spider-man right
the people in the in the space that are
trying to to to to have that
representation and have it be pro
whatever quote unquote proper or correct
do you think there's some pressure on
them to stay safe right and especially
like in the triple a space when you talk
about a spider-man right is there is
there pressure to sort of still tow a
certain line right and not go past that
it's a good question that's a good
question nobody
shout out to neil druckmann yeah
right
there's a reason why i say the last of
us is probably the greatest game i've
ever played
right because it was underlining issues
that no one i thought would attack it
right miles disney will never
allow you to do that sony will never
allow you to take those characters and
put them in a different space marvel
will never allow that
unless
it's you know uh written you understand
they have to write it in it that it is
in a safe format so that character is
bigger than the
being safe right you understand like the
character itself is too big for that
this is a great discussion i don't want
a sidetracked addict i'm gonna give it
to you i just want to push back on one
thing about this is a fantastic
discussion i just want to push back on
one thing in reference to the context
which is forza right and maybe it's from
a development standpoint it's like look
the reality is you're not really going
to see this avatar much right they show
them all the time i agree
i'm just trying to see
i know i know what i'm trying to say i'm
gonna give it back to you i totally
agree with you especially if they i
haven't played against icar.com you guys
are the reviewers i defer to you an
addict right pretty much well i'm just
trying but
that's what i'm trying to say is that
usually when there's something that i
have a problem with like because clearly
we all have a problem with this on some
level right
i always try to get myself in the
mentality of the developer as to why
this is happening right why are they
doing it why are we getting the jorts
why are we getting you know
like you know this half baked you know
thing from an otherwise
masterpiece experience right yeah and
that's the only thing i could think of
well maybe they say it to itself well
from the resource standpoint we don't
want to put in but i'll give it back to
you aj and attic i know you want to talk
not to go
i think the you know the thing that
actually is referring to is like every
time you want to match you see your
avatar cut scenes you see your avatar
uh you know you see avatar a lot and i
think that's probably their mindset it's
like you know if you put the pie on the
chart it's like what's the most
important the customization would be a
little probably smaller of the pie but
at the end of the day it's like to me if
you're putting the customization stuff
in
the the the uh the rolling wheel yeah
the spin wheels like i do feel like you
know you are putting an emphasis behind
the customization but then you're not
trying but you're not putting it okay i
guess
i'll get your points now now i
understand because you guys have played
it i had to sacrifice my leadership
nobody in chat is thinking that we hate
the game the game is amazing it's just
one thing that's felt often compared to
everything
especially considering the fact that
there's also like your avatar has voice
acting in the cut scenes like you're
always talking oh okay okay it to be to
be honest i felt like it should have
been extra you're in mexico the majority
of the the stuff you're going to be
wearing should be around the out the the
kind of clothing that they wear around
there right and if you want to look like
you would in another part of the world
that's what you got to unlock that's
what you got to get on oh true
to me if you're in mexico
it should be so like mexico right
there's no poncho
no listen to this
this is what's crazy there's a bunch of
lucha libre wrestling masks really
and it just felt weird and i do want to
talk about safety real quick because you
guys were talking about safety for
puerto rican culture and stuff like that
for i personally believe first of all
nobody who is like absolutely caucasian
like myself pale as as as the day
should worry because there's going to be
thousands of games right that's what i
always say is there's gonna be more
games but i do think that they were that
writers are still safe around
any color of gamer they are and the one
of the major reasons is because they
worry about the interactivity and i
talked to a viewer or i talked to a
developer just recently he's like dude
it's different than a a book or a a
movie i know what's going in that movie
and how it's written but a gamer can do
some crazy stuff we had that gamer who
killed a bunch of females in red dead
and they got their they got their
youtube and which i don't agree on the
youtube banning that seemed like odd i
was just like what but that goes to show
you those developers do think about that
and of course we have fable remember
fable allowed for killing of children
yes and the developer walked
peter saw the tester had a pile of kids
he was standing on and peter
it's out yeah go listen to this story
peter's like we allowed for killing of
kids and one of his
guys was like look at this and it's a
pile of children a dude with his sword
up and peter right then was like we're
done cut it off
but i agree with you guys like i thought
i thought miles was awesome because i
got to learn about stuff i like because
new york especially where i come from
like they don't have any lumberjack
games who are technically proficient in
gtx discussion either no it's like
that's not a big deal to me right
lumberjack simulator
the idea of all of us
being able to like
i don't know why i don't have that
mindset but to me keena
was like i was just like whoa what is
this which then got me to get a book and
go like what like for example we always
say viking stuff not to be rude but come
on after a while you're like dude we all
pretty much know the baseline but then
keena comes out and you're like i don't
know the baseline for this
what is this and i think that there's a
huge majority of gamers out there who
want to learn more and that the
developers
for some games will be safe right for
some games we'll do what miles did and
for other games they're going to push
and
that's what's awesome to gaming yes for
me right now is that there's so many
that there's someone out there pushing
oh you're too far but there's somebody
out there pushing now
i want to open it up real quick let me
see something real quick i honestly
think
a studio a support studio if they would
make a support studio like entirely to
be contracted for representation i think
that you know that that would be a good
thing like you know you hire they you
would hire the studio to make sure that
you get the customization right you get
how this you know the type of uh you
know clothing that each representation
would work every square enix game i got
to have spiky here
oh god just don't go there
i can't handle that shout out to delilah
because she points something on the
chest he says the voice acting is a
whole different issue they tried to make
it a continuation from four which is why
the character is british by the way yeah
so that was one of the things that again
i noticed it was the direct continuation
of like oh yeah this guy did great over
in in england and whatnot so they they
continue to continue and so therefore
the voice was what it was right
but it was one voice it was one voice
it's one female voice one male voice
that's pretty much it and i think to me
i get that part yeah but
nah nah listen
i get it this is this is honestly the
other day if you feel like these voices
can do it like
oh cool they can do it maybe because
some can't but it's just like you know
if you're about representation i'm not
saying they're not it's like yeah go
hire people from that community to
actually give more voices in that
community right now i want to switch it
for a minute because it's a great
discussion i want to get back on track
with one aspect that i've seen kind of
floating around and i'm very curious in
the realm here which i think about this
so we're gonna have some fun now
obviously this game is really reviewing
strongly right the open critic is out
there i believe it's still on what is it
the highest rating game of um excuse me
yeah looking at it right now with over
30 reviews so far forza horizon 5 is
currently the highest rated game of 22.
then we've seen the metacritic i believe
it came in about
91 which i'm looking at right now it's
getting extremely positive reviews
especially on um streaming a great
mobile streaming game because of the
accessibility you know graphical
fidelity ease of access all that stuff
so the question i bring to this
beautiful panel today on the round table
is um
can
a racing game
be nominated and win game of the year
yeah is it possible it is forza horizon
5
the one that could do it let me just let
me let me speak to this just real quick
let's go because i have such an issue
with the game of the year
the thing here's the thing if it can't
the person should never ever be allowed
to do a game of the year award it's
called game of the year
game of the year that's all games and if
that person cannot say that this
particular game is not a game and can't
be nominated for game of the year then
we have completely broken the entire way
in which we cover games
that is so
wrong that is so wrong and it's not even
because it's forza i would say it i gave
game of the year to some weird games in
the last couple years
and
and if anybody had the audacity to tell
me that that's that can't be game of the
year because of whatever like a walking
time simulator ethan carter one of my
favorite games if somebody said that
couldn't be game of the year i'd be like
dude you're gone like why are we even
talking about let's get it let's dive
deeper
i'm love that you said i just want to
push but i don't even push back i want
to ask you what they so because of what
you said how strongly you said it right
the question is
why
is the racing genre
in your opinion
like limited to even now to the point
everborn and we'll see
racing and sports combined into one
award
so the question is why what is the
mindset
that a game can't win it like what do
you think they're thinking people who
cannot be flexible in changing with the
environment yeah
old people that cannot be flexible and
changing and don't realize that that can
be a game of the year because i'm going
to tell you right now what is an
eight-hour game that's got some story
how can that be game of the year if a
game that offers 70 hours making your
own blueprints doing your own tunes your
own vinyls 3 000 layers of vinyls dude
i've seen people do vinyl stuff that
makes me want to cry because i have no
talent
i can make a square on the side of my
car at best and these dudes make homer
simpson like and it looks like
perfect right so those people are people
who do not share the flexibility and are
not understanding that games are dynamic
compared to what they used to be it used
to be just a couple games right and a
couple genres now we have an open world
remember when games you couldn't even
get out of the car yes it would be a
racing game and it's like you can't get
out of the car because the graphics
engine could not do it right now gta is
here
all bets are off no doubt everyone's
about to jump here
yeah so uh on on the um game awards
point yes um i i always find interesting
the dichotomy between the game awards
and the academy awards right
now every year
uh at the academy awards
the the big budget franchise
generally safe movies tentpole four
quadrant movies
those are the films that
may not even get nominated they always
win the technical awards but they never
win the big prize
right
uh but they usually geared towards the
more
original
typically lower budget uh more creative
projects
now
it's interesting to me that on the flip
side with video games and the video game
awards there's always an obligatory
indie game that gets nominated but it's
really only the big budget
uh 50 million hundred million dollar
four quadrant game that gets nominated
and it's sort of like so the oscars
shuns the popcorn movies and the video
game
industry uh praises them and i always
wondered why that is
and what does that say about those
awards can you chop it at the bit and
then i'm gonna open it up to king of
solvents no it's it's um
it's subjective okay you know to be
honest with you uh it every game is
worthy of game of the year
right that door is my game of the year
still right now i didn't get a chance to
play here it's not on game pass
shout out to king's rating system
passes
his criteria will be his game yes yes
yes
[Music]
he gets no bucks for me
it's only 20 dollars man
[Music]
he spends like a right this time
we see that spread i don't know
he's spending twenty dollars on butter
for the lobster that he gets
but he ain't paying attention
that is definitely a fraud alert i would
have to agree have a boy continue
[Laughter]
see again again there you go pocket
watching because at no point in time
four games
you want me to partake you can you see
what the chain says
you see what it says
i want you to partake in greatness and
not the marketing greatness yes but the
death story greatness that's all i'm
saying a lot of pocket ones okay though
it's okay though everborn because
usually when it comes to these indie
games man we pick up a couple to give
away so we balance it out yeah it's all
good continue
i have a theory we'll go to game pass
the day it launches on playstation in
november later this month and i'll play
it there um
continue the fact that these games are
subjective you know like it's it's what
do you view as game of the year is what
you view as a game of the year but these
people that are in control if they say
that oh this game doesn't uh
like reach certain criteria i thought it
was game of the year the object word
there that word there is game right so
if it's a game it's worthy to be put as
game of the year right so a racing game
forza can be game of the year because
a phone game a mobile game people have a
lot of problems when um what was that
game that y'all had a problem with
and it was the multiplayer game oh you
mean the one i was in my feeling
you coming for me okay no no no i'm glad
you brought that up because the game
that we king is talking about is um
overwatch and i watch a great game right
and i i just found it funny that the
same people who would gatekeep game of
the year for other type of experiences
that didn't have a narrative that's
those are the things i really gotta have
a narrative you gotta have this you
gotta have that and i when i found out
that overwatch didn't have that right
which no disrespect over i just thought
it was funny so that's why i'm like oh
so now that we know that you know for
the horizon and other games and
different genres that sometimes don't
have diary but have these other great
experiences is it okay now is it okay
now for those people who are gatekeeping
and trying to keep certain games out of
this mythical championship title
domination are we fully now open-minded
to include everything that's what i was
going out with i'm an anti-award show
right yeah i know you all i know you you
don't want nobody to tell you how to eat
your food
you're not gonna tell me what was good
or what sounded great or what i feel you
i don't care for anything they give they
give game of the year to games that
aren't out yeah
like look at some of those trailer stuff
will be like game of the year award and
you'll look at it you'll be like that
game's not out here
guys there's a couple extra months like
what calendar are they using it's just
oh
i would just like to see this year halo
infinite uh get it because they bent the
rules and allow it in and then win
just to eat popcorn and watch the world
you just want the burger king
are friends with certain individuals
i know where this is going
i mean
the the people who do do like a lot of
the behind the scenes for what gets
dominated and what not like there are
going to be it looks like some
conflictions like i don't know if it's
like conflictions i don't know
everything going on there i'm just state
i don't know the process behind all this
stuff uh but like to me when especially
when it comes to game of the year i've
always felt like to me the reason like
game of the year
i've always felt like that game that not
necessarily was the best of the year but
pushed the industry the most of the year
like overwatch that game came out that
year had its own uh had its own con like
almost out the gate like it i remember
it being like a phenomenal like sir it
was only a multiplayer center game but
everyone was talking about this game
like and i've always felt like we can't
have one and not the other like people
say
single player games got to be a game of
the year and i'm like that's not fair
because if it's a strictly multiplayer
game but it is the kind of the level and
the kind of like move the the needle
forward because
i don't necessarily because i wasn't
paying attention to transit stuff back
then but overwatch i felt like push that
um it was so dominant in that thing that
it kind of
killed hero shooters in its own way
because it's like yeah look we can't
compete with overwatch so let's try like
uh balinsky yeah where he tried yeah
law
what exactly happened to bleeding edge
like why did it just coming nobody
played it
it was really bland really yeah i felt
like they had a great concept they just
didn't build the walls so the walls fell
down like i i really i really feel like
if they would have actually i'm not
saying that you know the game was doomed
to the aim was going to come out if
microsoft didn't let it come out right
because i don't think they would have
finished it because of the way things
were going over there but it's just like
i've i love bleeding edge like i like
the way they did it i like it's yeah the
art design was good i just felt like you
know the core
of bleeding edge was good it's just they
needed to build around it better than
they did they needed more maps coming up
more content coming out they needed to
keep people in there and i just felt
like that's where they failed you know
uh what was that other game that came
out with overwatch that people were
comparing gigantic oh i know what you're
talking about
there was another one that was kind of
supposed to be in the overwatch video it
was made by uh i know it was about that
people make borderlands oh you don't
hurt me like i said i actually like it
more than overwatch i know the game
you're talking about um
it was a
battle battle i actually really like it
in like
situations like battleborn like i was
saying like overwatch was so dominant
when it came to its brand and how it ran
and it's part of that genre that
anything around it
couldn't even get on the mountain and
that's why i feel like you know in terms
of that game yeah uh there's a reason it
got game let me get started but i'm
sorry i got i got it because i want to
have to leave here in a couple i have to
leave here in a couple minutes
but like i really just feel like the
industry in general needs to restructure
how they do the game of the year stuff
i feel like sometimes it does go to you
know a friend of a friend i don't even
necessarily think it's a friend of a
friend or anything like that but i do
think there are some things that don't
make sense when stuff happens right and
like you know we were talking about the
like the indie game getting nominated
for game of the year it's like are they
nominating that game because they do
feel like it deserves to be there are
they doing it because they're throwing
the indie market a bone and like to me i
don't mind if stuff is there if it
deserves to be there and i'm not saying
the indie games haven't deserved to be
there right but it's like if you're
going to throw an indie developer a bone
i feel like that's more disrespectful
because you're giving them that spot
because you feel like you know you have
to for the indie scene then give them
that spot because they deserve to be in
that scene if that makes sense
to me that's setting that indy developer
up to fail because you know they're not
going to beat the competition but you're
putting them in there because you feel
like you have them in them
put them on the list but no no addict is
right attic is right and and i've been
saying this for years they do an
obligatory indie game nomination every
year and ask yourself when has it the
indie game ever won
but i think i think putting the
spotlight on it is in a lot of ways
helps a lot i don't know if it's setting
you know i don't think it's setting them
up to fail because it's putting on a
platform and then remember like
and i'll get into this when i start
talking it's it's you're up now
no no no no every category there's
categories that specify those games
right so for that game to sort of
punch above his weight and and be in
that category in addition to game of the
year
i think those are eyes on that game that
would not have been there otherwise so i
don't know about the failure part i
don't get that well it's it's it's not
that you know that's free promotion so
that you know maybe you're right on that
they are getting that free promotion i
would say like one of the the exceptions
to something like hades like hades was
the transistor so when you see those
type of games go up there you were like
okay i understand that but sometimes the
years be stacked y'all yeah we can't
admit that and then you see this random
indie game that he's like yo that was
good
to the final thing no that's good bro it
was a discussion i didn't want to stop
it it was a good organic discussion but
um solve like we talked about again the
game of the year thing you know is forza
horizon i know you haven't got a chance
to play i'm assuming you're gonna get a
chance no no i don't know you spread the
bread oh you're supposed to ice cream
are you part of the million
thank you i'll take that oh you paid
that preview can't continue i play i
played that 40 game pass spring room to
get a whole bunch of like cars and
whatever i forgot what it was right is
all that stuff earnable inside the game
probably if you play long enough yeah
probably yeah for sure you just want to
jump the line no this is not this is not
i'm not paying to win i'm not paying to
win you know what i'm saying i love i
love how king is praying about
everything but when it comes to buying
preachers yeah
[Laughter]
let me have a sound effect king i need a
sound effect
uh you know solve uh once you get the i
do want to talk about like yeah the the
stuff going on with like the game with
the game let's get it so let's get
started
we gotta get into
so when it comes to
uh the game of the year discussion yes
that's
to acg's point i think the game really
the game of your discussion is broken
already it's been broken right because
when you start
when keeley decides to do his
awards right which are the ones that
people most people consider the main
ones or whatever the case may be when
you're not doing them in january or
february
and you're omitting a good amount of
games that come out mid-november through
december it's a problem it's a problem
because you're admitting there's been
games like uh jedi fallen order right
what else yeah
in this year's case in this year from
what i've heard it's going to be halo
it's going to be foreign
i think forza apparently misses the cut
for the kiwis really
oh i didn't know that i'm not sure do
you think they should do it at the
beginning of the every year
absolutely they do it like january
february
absolutely
yeah absolutely they have to they should
do it that way that way you gave all the
games that come out in that calendar
year yeah it's called game of the year
exactly
how do you omit a good amount of games
and it's not like it used to be that you
know past november whatever 15th or
whatever you're not getting game
releases right game releases happen
every single month of the year now every
time is a good time to release the game
so for me that process is broken in and
of itself right okay a second thing is
that you give people a pass when you
have specific tiers and categories for
these specific types of games
as their own sort of game of the year in
that category and then you get people
passes like well if it's here then it
shouldn't be here or it won't be here
and then when you look at that game
within your discussion you have a lot of
third-person over-the-shoulder
action-adventure games it's the same
type of game all the time right and
people have this assumption about that
it has to be narrative driven it has to
be this super moving game and a lot of
times right not not i don't say a lot of
times that's that's too much right but
there are times that
the idea of playing the game gameplay
falls to the wayside in lieu of in lieu
of
aaa production value or whatever the
case may be a lot of times that happens
right um
a year that i it didn't happen without
surprise and for me it was sakura right
i picked second row and i was like
second row to me is the greatest playing
game this entire year right but because
of it because it's niche
and resp
compared to a lot of other games that
nominated i was like i don't know what
was going to do it right and it and it
did it and i was like oh my god i can't
believe this happened another time
it definitely deserved it right um so
for me
forza horizon 5 as it stands right now
and if by the end of the year this game
still i don't really care about
metacritic i don't know but it is a good
way just to aggregate numbers right do
you see the number if the aggregate of
this game is above all other games
and it doesn't and it doesn't have a
real shot at winning game of the year
there is a big problem
there is a big problem because this game
i think what horizon does
that
it gives you the open world formula that
a ubisoft game does right because it
does the same thing it has all the check
boxes it has all the things on the map
it's like oh my god i have too much
stuff to do
but the way that it breaks it down it
allows you to take it in bits and pieces
pause
it allows you to play the game in bits
and pieces
in a way
that those games do very well right if
there's anything i would change about
forza in terms of the formula after now
the fifth one yeah is
make the narrative stuff more important
right yeah maybe maybe the horizon
festival in and of itself could take a
little bit of a break right because it's
that same format right but in terms of
how they break down the open world for
you and in terms of how you engage with
that open world the different things i
think it does that perfectly and
beautifully and five is the is the
exemplification of that it is the
perfection of that it's ubisoft games
done
done done fun right it really is where
is that that repeatable task that you're
doing
is is different from moment to moment
enough so it's it's just continuously
fun to do and then when you look at the
game that runs and looks so beautiful
it's easy to stay in that world so for
me
if this game does not appear in point
blank game of the year discussion
you're going to boycott them
it's too too late for that late for that
buddy
be like me
and just
don't
watch oh stop it we got to watch because
we do it crowd your lord sir we do it
crowd
[Laughter]
[Applause]
how are you going to call it like
acceptably take the crown to put it on
your head and you're going to say you're
saying i watch it
no no no no no no no i didn't watch oh
yeah he's ridiculous i just reported the
music
one of those guys that would show up
late to his own wedding yeah it was a
forza discussion that's literally just
realized it he's like oh hang on dear
anyway anyway
that's classic
i want you to get your balls off before
you leave so again the last part with
the uh the controversy so to speak the
paid part early part i want you to get
that off before you go so there is an
issue that people are having with
you not getting game you're not getting
this game with the early access and game
pass maybe particularly more of the
ultimate um so at first i was like but
they've been doing this for a while now
so like you know this this uh this early
access thing actually predates game pass
so i didn't think anything of it
but uh i didn't know that gear's
ultimate yeah gears five like that earl
you got the early access from that one
on game pass so like i'm just sitting
here because i got gears five i got a
review code for gears 5. so like i'm
like
i'm sitting here thinking when i'm
looking at this i'm like i didn't know
that because i didn't play that through
game pass right because i usually play a
lot of the stuff but that particular
game i i i i i pretty much finessed and
i got a copy so question that because
i'm not understanding what the what so i
i got early access playing i'm playing
the game pass version right and i just
bought the expansion pass which gave me
the early access right so the game i'm
still playing the game
i didn't purchase the game out right i
haven't but see the thing is is
apparently like i said because of gears
5 because i that particular game i was
able to get through a website because i
that's the very first thing i ever got
from microsoft and like the only thing
besides horizon but when when you look
at it from that perspective if the
inconsistency is there i can understand
people being upset right you know they
were able to play that game when game
pass came day and day but not this one
right uh and and to me it's just like i
do understand people like i do think
that you know the early access thing
predates so they can't really complain
too much but i am understanding people's
people's annoyance when it's like yo you
gave me gears five on the early access
but not ult but but not four is of five
so it's it's like yeah i do understand
in terms of inconsistency on the people
that's in there in game past day let's
be real some people are drawn let me let
me ask you this
just real quick just for clarity the
thing that you guys i this is news to me
so solve that thing that you're talking
about it's called what where you are
you're paying for the dlc and the stuff
ahead of time you're playing for d right
you're paying for the dlc and stuff
ahead it's like the ultimate uh whatever
pack or something like he's impossible
it's like a ultimate versus standard
exactly but the thing about that is
special
exactly there you go that's exactly what
it is
i did the same thing i couldn't wait for
emma b to show i bought it right right
the difference here is this
th this pack once if you have game pass
already it comes down to like 40 bucks
right like 45 or whatever the problem is
that if you purchase the base game right
if you just don't go through game pass
and purchase the base game for 59.99
yeah
you don't get the early access so you if
you pay for the base game up front which
is more than this dlc edition yeah
you're right don't get the early access
which you should which
and you're paying more than i paid for
that experience so if you look at it
from the perspective of that
i think the reason that is because if
you buy this expansion correct me if i'm
wrong solve if you no if you lose game
pass you lose the game right because
that's not buying the game that's buying
the expansion it's not actually buying
the physics that is correct right so so
if you buy the actual game you don't get
the expansion stuff you just don't get
the hourly access access right exactly
because
yeah i didn't realize that just get the
base game you just get the base game
without the early access and without the
what is it right dlc you see that bass
whatever if you buy the homework dollar
pack with the cherry on top yeah you get
all of that all over it you get it all
so like my thing is like i don't i
completely
i i'm pretty much on the sides like look
game pass technically is
you get it day one when the game is
officially out there is uh you know a
point where you can get it early right
but if you you know you get that deluxe
edition but
i do understand where people are is like
yo like
i got geared so it's like wise gears
different than the fours of five and
that's where i do have an issue unless
unless the program existed around the
time didn't exist around the time
i think it was there
but the thing is this program has been
around for a while i remember giving
another another game that did it i'm
gonna ask you guys
for free the meals is over
but my thing is halo wars 2 had it it's
just i don't think you i don't i think
that predates game pass i don't remember
exactly so this this program has been
around for a while it's just to me
they're being too inconsistent right so
basically you're saying the program
needs to be consistent okay yeah
everyone needs to come in their little
round shape we'll be like look do we
want to offer ultimate the early access
to the ultimate member
or we do not want to regardless the
decision of that outcome they need to
keep that outcome yeah absolutely
absolutely here's ultimate because
it's been rumored that halo infinite's
going to have one right so if they feel
like hey well infinite is going to have
a better one and they like that they let
ultimate have that then people are going
to be upset that they didn't get uh with
verizon it's just i just want
consistency it's like i get that every
game does the same thing when in terms
of early access you can't have you can't
have certain games doing at certain
games not doing it because
to be confused
dudes whining about that
yeah i was gonna say there's a
difference between whining and a
difference between wanting i'm totally
cool with people having fomo and wanting
it but the efficient efficiency and
exactness across every single dev would
be great but i don't think it's
realistic
i think it's okay that we do have the
occasional one
what you know what forza should have
done real quick and i'll let you go is
that i believe forza should have said
there's some pre-races or something
you know like there's something there's
an event
there's things that matter prior and
then people it's more fomo but at least
then you have a reason versus it's the
same thing as everybody could get
because that does feel weird but it just
feels weird it doesn't feel like i mean
dude it's game pass already at some
point you have to be like
and i don't let me say this because i
literally have to leave um
obviously four minutes i only got four
he's getting the most out of this four
minutes y'all you're getting the most
you're getting them more now he got 14
he got 14. at 4 14 but we ain't going to
say no longest yeah yeah his ips is high
but
look okay look beside that we got four
minutes interrupts for seconds late
continue
okay
i agree with you but i do feel like in
terms of their first party stuff they
can be more
they can't be more on the part of it's
like that's all i'm asking it's like i
don't really care i'll wait it doesn't
really matter to me but as far as like
the members that subscribe to this it is
weird that they get one game and not the
other early access like it's either give
them all early access or don't give none
of them early access be more like in
terms of the first party stuff you know
what i'm saying
like i can like you know back for blood
that's different that's third party
stuff they can't have a whole lot of
control over that but their stuff the
horizons the the halos the the gears
just make sure that's consistent bro
they can't even get the game with co-op
so i don't know if halo is the gold
standard sorry i'm i'm pretty negative
so you guys have a good day
does he do like public transit no no he
drives down
yes
just i just had a thought yes
let's have a thought about the eternals
and thanos was right after if you see it
you know yeah yeah oh you know davis was
right there's right yes i'm with you i'm
with you that's right i want to get a
t-shirt that says right right um but
see i feel like in this whole
conversation with early access i think
people are forgetting what the
definition of early is
because i hear a lot of people talking
about oh i thought it was day and date
day and date is november 8th or 9th
whatever the day it comes out early is
early and you can pay extra for that if
if you want the fomo package like says
but i don't think it's a big deal right
when you got it right this is the thing
like this is why you can't give people
nothing
they get exactly years
now now we need everything early right
so the thing is yes there are exceptions
to the rule but the standard release
date is the standard release date and
that's it anybody saying anything
otherwise are they're either spoiled
or they're being disingenuous there's
only there's no there's no in between
there
i mean i should i shouldn't be surprised
but
why would anybody remember that like
that they got gears i'm going to tell
you what
let's just go get these they're dwarves
from warhammer 40 000. the books are woe
man gamers will have a little notation
they'll be like 17 years ago i got this
45 minutes late and i'm not lying i have
friends who will say stuff and i'll be
like what the are you talking about and
they're like yeah man go back and look
and you have to look at like the dark
web and the old archive internet to find
a web page where someone oh
get out of the chat i see you anyway
i'll get my balls over this went crazy
low but it was a great discussion look
great great discussion i i'm with you
guys i'm with king and with everborn in
a sense that i don't really have a
problem with that stuff i know what it
is it is the fomo package this i think
we will continue to see more of this as
these games these big blockbuster games
are in game pass and to me it's no
different than when ea played because i
was a big man head back in the day and
either play oh four or five days ahead
you could you could play the trial demo
that could transform into the full
retail if you want it early and it's up
to you to maintain discipline but i'm
with everybody in the sense that at the
end of the day on the specific release
date it's going to be free and game pass
this is there's a difference between
that and early access but in early
access yeah so that's what i was going
to say as far as the game itself it's
great to see if you paid that money
extra yeah
well we called it expected access yeah
because people just expect it now right
right it's not coming on tuesday right
you paid you deserve it
let's deserve it we know how you feel
yeah it's just
stop it now now you have too much money
this is what it is you have too much
money and and you should have to pay for
the dlc now because you have too much
money now i can't realize that they said
they have more money than cents i can't
this is what it is you they gave it out
with gears and they still realize you
know we could have sold this to these i
mean i don't i don't appreciate that i
mean pocket watching because
there's money to be spent like no
it's not i'm just talking about the
people that are complaining that me
in game pass have the same exact uh
bonuses that you have unless i wan i
don't want to play early i don't care to
play well the bonuses like i said you if
you play long enough you can earn them
you can earn them put the pocket watch
into the chat
the same t-shirt you pay 45 for i can if
i drive long enough i can't oh no no
this is the thing though i'm not i'm
definitely not like if they're talking
about cosmetics i'm not doing that you
better get you got to give me tracks you
gotta give me cars like cosmetics
you know who i'm at
the people that are waiting until
tuesday and they salty looking at the
one million players who spent that money
to come oh no that's right oh yeah i'm
waiting
i got the review code you know but i got
to be a responsible leader give it to
the site give it to the podcast you know
what i'm saying put the codes out and i
literally could have paid for it but i
was like you know it's going to come out
i'm going to get it but i wish you
everybody i'm not mad i made that
internal decision i need gingerbread
now question question the million dollar
question yes
if they offer early access for halo oh
are you waiting yeah okay
i'm not even gonna fall in front i'm not
i'm a fraud
i'm not gonna have my entire friend list
doing it up on campaign like oh yeah
when you see that friendlist
there's no way i will definitely and
i'll be your victim of the fomo there's
certain games i am not waiting for gang
king i see you yeah
you look at your friends listen you see
me playing destiny
and this is for everybody else because
you probably don't know i don't play
betas yeah i know you don't you know
you're not available and they were doing
all these test flights and and they
flying around i need a little jet you
got a beta boy
he was doing all that stuff right there
i did not care he's a reform base he's a
reformative boy he used to be out there
he needs to be justified you should be
tossing it up this is how the baby boy
emoji used to do right now
and this is this is where i'm afraid and
i put this on me
if there's something that i care about
exactly we all do it we all do it but i
care about halo but i care about it
enough that i don't care about the
multiplayer i care about the campaign
look
we got we got to move on because this is
what's going on lastic like i said
playground salute
i'm sorry five five seconds okay uh
you will be playing destiny if halo
comes out early but let's just give a
shout out to all the people who will
stop playing destiny after december 8th
and come back home oh yeah say hey
coming back oh yeah we already know
what's going on all right we bracing for
impact over the dancing community we
know what's about to happen
the
we talked about it last word this week
we know us about that but that's these
they've that's how they do they just go
in the bunker they wait for impact then
they come back outside in february
but look the last thing we got to put
respect on the playground's name
they're definitely up there in the
hierarchy we you know i i cannot say
enough about them as far as game studio
the future looks bright fable people
have a lot of confidence and then the
last thing i'm gonna say just for the
end of the year microsoft's finishing
strong you know you know between this
you know we have flight simulator
psychonauts you know this is a this is
probably the first time in a long time
that i remember microsoft not only
having a strong year but almost to
themselves in one way right
it's very dumb and it's good to see and
they're really pushing themselves under
the christmas tree and no packages for
you
speaking of this year though like think
about this in the last 12 months
microsoft first party since then i just
wanted i want to name some things off
and you tell me and i want before i name
them off the lowest score here is an 82
and the highest one is a 91 and we're
gonna count a bunch of different games
and what genres they're in okay here's
tactics right
on xbox right
hive busters right right
um
flight scene yes
psychonauts yes
um
you also got forza but death loop is
another one that came out on pc right
um age of empires right forgot about
that
so that that that's seven
games
all developed
by microsoft first party studios in
vastly different genres and each of them
are best in class at what they are doing
they're up there yeah again lowest score
82 you can go check the meta right now
highest score 91.
think about that no it's impressive and
that that's the thing that i know they
gotta hang their head at very impressive
we gotta move on solve you wanna get
these joints and then we move on to the
next
yeah absolutely hold on one second i'll
help you out too as well when i pull up
because it's a lot stuff that wins i got
so the last one let me get this last one
yeah copy and paste it um
let me just read it first don't know
taku five dollars which fable ain't a
hit unless the hero of albion ain't a
sad dad wow make the rules stop it stop
it
stop it okay now i'm gonna roll back a
little bit
we got
uh
[Music]
okay the dutch rudder five dollar stupid
chat
taught my daughter how to make flan
watch coco canelo won and i'm going to
mexico on forza horizon 5. it's been a
per it's been a person mexican heritage
week for me
absolute
no doubt no doubt then we have
hold on a second
then we have michael
uh two quid michael okay let me read it
correctly it's titch bond so michael
jackson two quid super chat two quid for
correction it's pronounced titchbon okay
yeah i will get that right from now on
thank you for correction
then we got spartan ghost five pound
super chat wanted to say i found acg's
youtube with forza horizon 4 in 2018
review opening with hilarious respect
all right also row boat ryan paddling to
2022 with no messy messy we missed flame
let me get flayed fight out some chat it
was great being on here if only i had it
oh you got him okay yeah it was it was
next oh okay got it okay to make sure
yeah flame fighters which that was great
being on here if only for a few minutes
i appreciate being given the opportunity
to write for lognet now let's get that
manscaped ad
working on it
then we got spartan ghosts to get five
possibly chat wanted to say i don't know
i got that that one twice then we got
heart gate chaney yeah five dollars
super chat three out of the last four
tens by ign games from xbox flight sim
death loop for the horizon five we
forgot about that too yeah xbox has
bangers yeah hope halo will also be a 10
quality and quantity in game pass
yeah
then we got clutch man 10 super chat
can't wait for forza horizon 5 to hit
game pass soon it deserves a game of the
year nomination because a good racing
game like like this one keeps you
constantly engaged and not putting down
the controller during the cutscene now i
want them to hold it to next year when
gran turismo will come out and then go
ahead
messi
continue and we got the wise old gamer
five dollars super chat the realism in
forza horizon 5 is awesome in my play
time my car got stolen and sold for
parts and my character got decapitated
by the mexican mafia wow which forza was
you playing yeah
for 11 months shout out to doobie 650
plus in the chat hit that like button
yes all right hit that like button
everybody
then we got don otaku five dollars super
chat can't wait to play sims 5's without
character creation and only be able to
be a sad dad wow wow
there we go flame five dollar super chat
it won't be nominated for the for
keeley's game of the year jeff grubbs
said nominations were sent in weeks
before they had a chance to play forza
that's a shame that's a shame that seems
calculated it's not gonna lie oh [ __ ]
lie that that doesn't make sense man
that just doesn't make any sense that's
really changed
boycott splendiferous two dollars super
chat 2021 is an indie year and indy
better win game of the year
he's for sure and we got donald taco two
dollars hades was game of the year 2020.
i don't care what no one says yes that
is correct
that's dora's game of the year 2021. og
and also 20 21 exactly yeah ogtk cole
five dollars we chat i know you guys
aren't saying names but how did jeff
keeley get so much power in the first
place he is biased
nice come on now let's start with the
person
he's nice
oscars regardless of how anybody may
feel that's something that's a gamer you
you do want we continue yeah then we got
pixel with g two live super chat since
killer instinct xbox's free to play
model has been the base game
all right
then we got jb gold in 10 dollars which
had the ultimate edition of gears 5 was
given out to everybody who subscribed to
game pass ultimate when it first debuted
did any first game after offer the
premium edition for game pass
yeah so that was it it was they gave you
the premium edition like okay i get that
yeah
i give you a hundred dollars one time
and now every week you come back
ultimate game the game pass game pass
wasn't as good of a service and we
didn't have as many great games
especially day and date games that is
true and we got drunken ninjas out drunk
and ninja for in a member for 15 months
next four next four's a horizon six
gonna be set in japan they should make
it come up story where you work your way
to the festival kind of like forza
horizon one okay all right yeah so some
some some narrative differences would be
welcome
drunken ninja five dollars which they
can do early access for people that are
game pass ultimate members for more than
six months or a year
i mean they could do all that sort of
stuff but i my feeling is that that's
just it's
it's too much
they could also not do that and exactly
give you the games when they come out on
day one right and i don't mean early
because a lot of us forgot the
definition of early they could give it
to you when they say it's going to come
out like they're doing with force and
that's it yeah all right so we got a
couple more we got the wise old gamer
five dollars with a chat after 18 years
of marriage you get used to paying for
early access
once you start paying it becomes a [ __ ]
wise old gave him time
you are messy sir you are messi never
never ceases to he never sees you
amazing
gaming forte five dollar super chat i
was super close to buying that package
but i stood my ground hashtag i'm not
rich i worked at gamestop always
shout out to the gamestop employees
shout out to y'all y'all doing y'all
doing the lord's work over there forte
your your lawn would beg to differ i saw
that yeah
i don't know
hello he ain't waiting all right
you can play a baseball game on that
lawn seriously
oh as always hey king boo-boo
[Laughter]
here we have heart geet shanee five
dollars of attack cross platform gran
turismo 7 playstation in 2022. ford's a
motorsport for series consoles wonder
who will win um
i told you we all caught up you hit him
i believe we're caught up yes all right
keep talking oh elden ring what is
happening what's going on
um
elgin rin looks good bro what can i say
like for me
i was that dude that was initially not
into any sort of souls game right i was
like i don't have the time to play this
i don't have the time to rip my hair out
that i don't have um i don't have the
time for it until i just decided one day
to sit down and try right right
and what i found is that unlike a lot of
people like i don't get i'm not i don't
get frustrated by getting my my my ass
handed to me all the time like i don't
yeah pause
i don't
i enjoy it i enjoy like learning the
patterns and stuff that we did when we
were younger right these difficult
platforming games we're about to make
attic play
but but souls does it in in the combat
context in a way that for me i find very
satisfying when i learn and finally beat
a boss right second row uh
one of my like i
granted i have not beaten any one of
these games all the way through because
i don't finish games because i don't
have time
when i played second row second row was
so great to me because it did that thing
where it changed up the formula where it
was like okay
you you can't grind to get better you
just have to get good right and you just
have to be good at pairing you just have
to be good at fighting and
you're going to have your different you
your weapons and stuff like that your
different sort of items that you can use
in combat but at the end of the day
there is no xp grind for you just to get
stronger it's not there
and for me
i love that but i know that wasn't for
everybody so i think in all these these
souls born games when you go from demon
souls to dark souls to bloodborne all of
them added a little bit something
different to the formula
that i think now
in second row of course culminates with
elden ring which to me is the amalgam of
all of those different systems in a way
that i think also fans
it seems like they're going to be on
board with they're giving you the more
open world they're giving you more
options in terms of how you fight you
can fight on the on on the back of your
horse and stuff like that um the speed
that i saw in this 15-minute sort of
trailer was akin to what you might see
in like a bloodborne but then you also
had the heavier type of combat that you
get from a dark souls and whatnot and
then i don't i'm not really sure how
secure plays in right because it still
seems like it's more in that vein of you
you can grind and get stronger whatever
yeah but for me
what was great about sakura apart from
that was the fact that when you fight i
love fighting human-like opponents in
games that have the skill level that i
have because at that point it becomes
like a real sword fight right it's like
back and forth parrying stuff like that
when you're fighting these super
monstrous beings and stuff like that
it's about you finding a way to get at
them it's not necessarily hand-in-hand
fighting you getting around their beasty
crazy attacks so i think eldon ring has
it just it just seems like it is
everything they've ever done in these
games put together in one game to sort
of satisfy every type of souls born uh
fan
and you know i know eight is actually
still here yeah i'm here okay okay
so it's right there this is what happens
when i'm quiet people yes we're not used
to you guys that's what it is
so i'm excited to hear carrick's take on
this because i think this
i know why people are really excited for
this and i kind of think it's going to
hit that i don't know that it's going to
bring new people in but i think i really
do think that for people who either
prefer
souls or prefer bloodborne or or love
sakura i think this is the game they're
going to give them a little bit of all
of that so that makes it super exciting
for me because i really do think this is
the one that's going to hit
super big um even though bloodborne
people love bloodborne obviously
but for some reason this one feels like
it is the one
no don't no doubt let's get acg man why
are you feeling i know you wanted me to
talk behind the c he's like we just held
the ring
so i was the same way i was not excited
too much about elden ring because i
don't get into the glitz too much of
like people talking about what they did
but then i saw that and dude
okay so you look at all these ones you
look at surge you look at this because
the surge games did their this sci-fi
which i really like surge 2 in
particular
and all of these have a difficulty of
trying to separate neo from hero how
does that separate
and
what separates this from the others is
the magic
and the open world well the open world
in the way that they've added skills so
you don't gather skills um by leveling
up you gather them around the world and
i liked that i like that idea of making
that world larger but what surprised me
the the more and more i looked at it and
the more i saw it and the more i started
to to identify things you had stated
that there isn't a grind you know to get
experience there isn't you are the
experience bar the player
the experience bar is not on the screen
that's you
grinding maybe dying but learning
experience on your own it's no longer
experiences on the character you can see
it and then they go up a level and
something happens instead you have to go
up a level and they've tried and
attempted and some people haven't got
into it i do also believe that this is
most likely the one that will probably
gather the most people because they also
did something that the prior ones didn't
do it's flashier and i know that a lot
of people aren't gonna like me saying
that but it is and that does matter to
people and what you saw was i'm a
dragons dogma fan for instance
attack where it lands into the ground
you fight it and then at the starting of
this video they showed the dragon land
and i was like oh my god finally
everything's bigger everything's like
stretched out there's larger areas to
fight which then allows for you to
adjust and use your magic which they
showed some really cool magic
everything about that interested me it
uh you know graphically it's not going
to be your top tier because it is from
software who
they they have a weird grittiness to
everything they do sort of this almost
clumsy here's our version of a dragon
you're like that's a little different
but you're like okay whatever and
everything about that interests me i'm a
huge fan of sakiro but i do believe that
a lot of people got turned off of that
because it was such a different style of
gameplay we had to worry about your
guard their guard sometimes their guard
did this and i know a lot of people who
had if issues with that didn't have
issues with neo i personally believe
that will be the same thing for almost
all the games if you had issues with
surge or issues with dark souls or
issues with securo there is a high
chance here that there'll be enough
flexibility that you will not have
though you will be able to play
to what you consider
to be like more your style and it's
going to be difficult i'm i'm going to
tell you right now
behind the scenes and i was like i would
not want to qa that game because dude
there's no fall damage
and that means you can screw with things
they showed him falling and like coming
behind somebody and i'm like oh can you
imagine trying because dude sakiro the
the ogre with the chains who had the
horrible
hitbox he could grab you from like 800
it was it was sort of glitchy
this is even this is 10 times that if
you're a qa guy you got to figure out
this the player won't just come towards
me they can bounce off a tree
bounce off a rock and come down like how
do how do we balance all that it is
going to be it's going to be even if
it's bad i cannot wait to see it because
i want to see like
how from software makes an open world
yeah let me ask you this because i want
to put on your azure question references
the mechanics if you've heard anything
we know they're implementing the co-op
right now is it a full implemented co-op
is it like or is it segmented certain
thing like what do we know so much about
the call it is full it is full of from
what i talked to one of the faq like
websites it is a
it is more full than the prior ones but
it may not be as like
you know it may not you don't start
doing follow-up got you like
everybody's a master chief i guess
gotcha
but from what i understand there's that
there's the summons which looked and by
the way kudos to them how many times
have you summoned a guy in a game and
the bad guy ignores the summons
seriously
he's a ghostly dragon why would you not
worry about him and in this game the guy
summons like a goblin and dude turns
towards goblin and i had this moment of
like yes realization where i was like i
because i'm not a huge from fan i mean i
am but i'm not
i'm not like those die hard from fans
but i'm i do see what they're trying to
do and i saw that and i was like kudos
to them because other devs are gonna
look at that and be like oh
yeah you know we have let this slide a
little we've just let you do the summons
and here he summons like six
the little ghouls is on the little
sprinkles
which is the
the spike club and they're all hitting
him and i'm just like this is and i
think that'll allow a player who maybe
gets me that that was for me when most
of the time you see a battle in dark
souls and your brain sort of dies you
die a couple times because you're so
overwhelmed here i have this feeling
there's going to be strategists and then
the skill thing just one last thing the
skill thing is so cool because the idea
of one of you guys telling me in dms
like oh hey i found a skill that does
this behind this ogre over here and i
can go okay that's exactly where that is
i don't have to level up i know where it
is i can go towards that early if that's
my gameplay style and the trading of
social signals that people will have and
that's that's such a pr word i don't
know any other word to say it but i'm
just saying the ability to say this
thing's over here
oh my god i found this skill over here
and that can totally adjust your
gameplay style it
and boy it looked like a painting i
don't okay last last thing no go go for
it
when when todd howard came out he was
like see that mountain you can go to it
one of the problems with todd saying
that is that every game after that
wanted to show you graphically that what
you were seeing you could go to which
includes sharpness and detail right
look at eldon ring's trailer again he
comes out to an area and the background
is almost solid almost no movement and
it's all oil painting and i love that
from was like screw that we're going to
go the exact opposite route we're going
to make it so that it looks like a
fantasy world and when you break into
that spot in elden ring they first show
him walking out there's all this area
it's a oil and i grew up you know old
style like brom and caldwell and uh and
larry elmore with their huge fantasy art
where it looked oil painting like and no
game has done that for a long time
because they've all wanted to show the
tech and here the art seems to be
elevated and i can't wait i can't wait
oh what what's going on he ended up
getting a call
it's addict
are you serious i'm like bro you cannot
be calling me well i'm like and that's
like someone got shot like bro
we will deal with it later some of the
the poll
copy paste near the poll i'm like this
man i knew he was gonna do this i just
knew he was gonna do this what is he
talking about
just copy paste that he felt this was so
urgent i'm like bro no
anyway emma boy what's good
yeah man so i i saw this trailer i've
never really been in the souls games
like that i've played a few of them over
the years but nothing
um
i get frustrated fast
so
um yeah i'm like this
this this
i don't know why
but i watched this trailer especially
with that pot with the arms and the legs
that was stuck in the ground yeah i got
real breath of the wild vibes from from
watching it
um
and it's like if you mixed uh
i don't know breath of the wild with
with um
the witcher 3 and with that the dragon
fight
and the weird character designs but i
like what i saw
and i'm interested to see if uh with uh
george rr martin being attached to it if
this well i guess that i'm probably
answering my own question but i was
gonna say maybe the story will be a
little bit more coherent but then you
read the game of thrones books and you
realize absolutely not this might be uh
one of the most hard to follow games uh
in in in in seoul's born history uh but
i i am at least hoping that um
the the the names and the um
and the characters are interesting so i
am uh it's one of those things where i
feel like i'm obligated to play it
because everybody's talking about it but
i genuinely don't care about it i'm not
even going to lie that was fast
respectfully listen
i could i'll jump in right now because
you literally resonated to be like i am
the soul fro like i am not touching that
souls fraud i like
the reason
i respect what that series is doing like
truly like really and truly now younger
cog who is adventurous who wants to put
his skills to the test and and challenge
the greatest at the top that would have
been me i'm going to honk with a job
yeah cop with a job cog with four
podcasts cog with a website
it's just uh you're not gonna get me to
go home and be mad and throw controllers
at a screen because i can't beat you
know the first boss
that i encounter along my path as soon
as you came up
respect like i'm not trying to trash
this kid these these games are amazing
but i will say what i will say is that
when i seen this to acg's point
they had enough of stuff for cog
i was like okay you're doing some stuff
i was like because i i'm always been a
fan of games where you can have minions
you'd be like go seize them get them
like your own ads
put your own ads out there yeah bro i
love so i was like okay then they coming
for me because my old i always would
fraud i'd be like well until they make a
full real co-op songs then maybe i'll
try they like get [ __ ] we got that for
you what's up what's up guys
you gonna bend the knee now so i'm like
oh okay all right i'm not going for it
it looks beautiful what was it that
storm something castle
oh my god it looks gorgeous even the way
like you do the horseback i don't know
if it's some type of spirit animal thing
that he's traveling on that he's kind of
teleporting and stuff looks absolutely
jumping a little too high for me
i will say this though it i like when he
you know you got the outside the
spacious areas but i liked also they got
the dungeons it was giving me skyrim
elder scrolls vibe you know what you
used to work the tunnels you fight the
dragger and you got to they had the
little tunes like i used to like stuff
like that so i'm like
damn they're coming for me the
executions are visceral you know what
i'm saying but to kings what king i know
king i know listen i'm about to bring it
back before you give me a fraud alert
i'm about to bring it back now listen
i wish i say all that to say this
this is probably the most
honest attempt for them to try to get me
i still don't know if i'm doing this so
i'm with you on that king but i want to
give it to them because this is us a
soul's fans dream
it is an open world souls game it looks
phenomenal i like to see
that you know the community get what
they want and i just my last question is
i just want to know
is there going to be a tethering almost
like a state of decay co-op
right
how are they going to hit because to me
that's like
this is a very character-driven souls it
seems it's very you know so i'm like how
are they going to execute that if if i'm
in it and you're in it you know can i go
to the other side of the map like
because we saw what state of the cape
ever remember acg and with that circle
yo makes it so painful the first time i
played it yeah yo don't go to manhattan
stay in the bronx you too when the guy
just starts bouncing and you're like
what's happening then you realize it's
all tethered you're like exactly no
we gotta figure it out
i gotta see how they do that but bend
the knee to them on that soft i don't
know i wanted you to get your balls off
there we go
i mean yeah definitely yeah sorry
okay no
all right so listen like blood born
right my my foolish mortal self um sore
bloodborne and was like everybody's
talking about this
crazy hair man let me get the game i
couldn't beat the werewolf when you came
out today
i didn't know that you didn't even have
to beat the wolf you could have just
left right you gotta die you gotta die
you just left out the door i fought this
werewolf for two weeks straight
all right
i'm at uh microsoft uh uh fan fest
and um
the screen is beautiful that's when they
had the 4k screen
and it was like from software the crowd
go crazy i just turned around i'm like
why y'all going crazy
right and then
suck it up
and i'm like oh my god it looks so
amazing
not knowing that it was the souls game
you thought it was like a classic did
you get any though did you get it came
back
since you came back
not knowing buddy
you've been in this dance before it
didn't go good for you all right okay
whatever
that's the year we did that stupid
awards yes
securo won yup
this okay this is a reason why it's a
lot of things i'm opposed to
i'm opposed to metacritic
i don't need you to chew my food to tell
me it's nice i respect that i want my
own food i want to taste myself respect
right so it was rated super high right
yeah
game game of the year it even had it on
my box yes because my foolish mortal
self went out because an award show told
me what was nice and metacritic was
serious this is it
i got it in my house
and the terror came back
i played that game literally i know how
you crawl back into the little hut and
you get a knife and you come outside
that's as far as i got
[Laughter]
let me tell you something
about your
little elden ring oh
monster
from software that was when you was out
it was the dark souls of trailers for
him he came up difficulties too high for
me to watch this
who developed this and i'm good
i
watched that trailer with such vigor in
my heart oh
knowing
there's no way in hell
i'm going to give you box gotta be
informed guys
then i might check it out right but
this part right here
but that little man in the back of my
head said don't you believe them
i don't know king even if it's king even
if it's in game what if it's a gamepad
no no no no no no time is money thank
you for saying that by the way no man
enough people don't realize that
you're right and you know what i do also
um
i like sample i like to go
yeah so i was any you know skin off my
back to download you trust you out you
don't you don't act right in my presence
you guys
i got the uninstall button and you will
be uninstalled and sent away but i can't
get rid of second though
yeah
like a like a like a ghost
haunting its pale soul staring at my
face every time i decide to look at from
software and say
that's where i want to be so from
software you're from the bushes and
that's where you will remain
king said he will try out a game
open the door car door for the game and
then walk around the cover and she don't
reach over and open the car door
brockdale
i mean but i i gotta give y'all props
though because you know you know yeah
yeah i don't play these anymore right
but i mean but y'all played y'all played
the predecessors to these yeah in a lot
of ways those are harder because those
games do not
they they run well back then right right
when you talk about kingsfield
kingsfield yeah
was so difficult
so difficult
and it was just it was them trying out
this idea of
how about we make a monster closet yeah
that's impossible for you to beat yeah
and
and
obviously they've refined that over the
years right
see what you're missing out is
cog and i oh yeah we used to play that
game
[Music]
yeah i got it early we got it earlier so
we wrote we was the original beta
we wrote boys
everything potions
everything what a nishkana means here
what this means here and we put it down
and we played it and we figured it out
this is not the same thing
don't you ever say king's field
represents what sekito is because it was
no parry button that i had to have five
seconds but i'm talking about that type
of game i'm talking about second row
because techno is a different beast than
the rest of them by the way
even from from software fans that is a
different it's it is a different beast
bloodborne was somewhat different with
the offensive stance where it was more
about killing to get power which we're
not accustomed to right right hero even
for me dude i have
some behind the scenes of me playing
that and it's pretty rough it's it's
like it's overrated
your parry game is not on point you're
in trouble it's not only that sovereign
it's later on you get guys where you
have to treat them opposite of what
you're
what you've been doing what you've been
taught to do yeah which is good it's
just
it it's there's a lot yeah and i do
believe that i do believe that eldon
ring
knows that that can be a lot and what
they're doing is they're offering it'll
be just as difficult they've even said
one difficulty
so we've got the one difficulty but i do
firmly believe that ads if cog wants to
play ads may be a viable i think dark
souls made you play
even though it it was like classes i
think it sort of made you play its way
right where it feels like eldon ring
might have i mean dude the horse imagine
this a horse or on foot that already is
so dynamic in a battle the difference is
so dynamic so
i'm excited man i mean i get what you're
saying
for me i'll buy it for you
his camera was like seriously carrick
don't get it for him
okay you're back
we are good brother yeah everybody got
their balls all fought uh
oh did you alright let's move oh sorry
good
uh let's get some of these super chats
bro okay um
let me roll back a little bit
it's not too many we have uh auburn king
two panels will be chat xbox reward
points made premium and easy buy yeah so
if you had those report points in the
bank you
didn't pay anything um lord metroid
shout out to lord metro lord for two
months acg and the iop is the only two
podcasts i watched great elderly video
carrick assaf finished metroid which is
my game of the year keep up good work
guys yeah i continued to truck away on
metroid i forgot about that yes um i'm
loving metroid red the one thing that
i'm a little annoyed with is metroid
obviously the maps are
any metroidvania it's the map to sort of
kind of and the genius in how they
intertwine that map is kind of a big
part of the game
so with metroid red though there's a lot
of points where they just give you warp
points to go to different places right
which kind of makes me think that they
were like well we kind of we we put
ourselves into a corner here with how we
designed this let's give them a way out
and
yeah
i'm not a fan i'm loving the game i'm
loving the game but that aspect of it if
you look at past metroid maps to me in
terms of the way they're built
i think the intertwining of them and and
it's funny we're talking about that
because i think dark souls it does a
great job of that too the map sort of
kind of doubling back on itself in very
interesting ways
this kind of these warp points feels
like they were like oh no we messed up
let's give them an out so
i'm loving the game i'm loving the
gameplay i love the way samus plays and
moves fantastic but that is
that's it no doubt what else we got
that's it i think we're gonna hold up
and let me see if we got any more yeah
we got brian lane yeah brian lane
beating sakura was my favorite gaming
moment yeah beating second row is an
achievement when i saw attic do that i
was like god
i wish i wish my brother would play
those games because yeah because he's a
savant with that too like if he gets
into it it'd be crazy absolutely bonuses
if he's in here he bonds as a beast but
let us move on next time it's a big one
y'all this is king if you don't mind
i'll set it up for you
um
yeah man big one sega and microsoft to
explore strategic alliance to create new
strategic titles for sega and establish
a next generation development
environment so this has been going on on
the interwebs a lot of talk so i'll just
give some brief comments obviously from
um yukio sagino president and ceo sega
corporation we're very pleased to
announce today that we are considering a
strategic alliance with microsoft to
help develop sega's new super game
initiative as well as build a next
generation game development environment
and then again just uh just going to
summarize real quick and then we have
comments from sarah bond ccvp microsoft
sega has played such an iconic role in
the games industry has been a tremendous
partner over the years we look forward
to working together as they explore new
ways to create unique gaming experience
for the future using microsoft cloud
technology together we will reimagine
how games get built hosted and operated
with a goal of adding more value to
players and sega alike hey hey cobb can
you remind me what part of the company
sarah bond works for i believe she works
for the xbox the ocean oh yes that's
interesting okay i'm sorry okay i know
what you're doing sir so look this is
kickstarter he had a lot to talk about
in our ilp
personal chats so
oh
is that what i think it is i got a
picture
gig the floor is yours sir what do we
have to say what's going on here
i love to love you baby
who is the fraud alert for i'll tell you
wait hold on
i asked you
what they needed to do for you to bend
the knees
who did you ask i need to
i
know
dominus maximus aurelius spencer please
make this happen
two weeks to the day oh
sega is here to play
i'll camp with you oh i like the jedi i
like that card that's very clean sir
very clean
is this for a certain lord i i still
don't know who it is you're talking to
this is a level of flex that
you don't see much of
like you don't see much of a flex like
this like
this level of flexi because what he's
going to try to do is he's going to try
to wiggle his way out oh is he you still
have not
so you implying that saul is in trouble
that he dead besmirch your prediction he
knows what it is
okay he knows what he did
you know
like a child in trouble
literally a randy macho man
yes but he knew
not to mess with me but he did anyway
so what happened what i had to do
i don't really take the shades off every
so they knew when i looked into the
camera
you're very fine
straddling the line
this is a great problem get out of lay
down oh
you know what the queen did
what'd she do
she was in places she didn't even have
to be over there
that was letting you know exactly what
she was doing what was really
she she gave her
eloquent speech
and congratulating
the partnership yes
what the vision she works for yeah she's
an xbox unlike the sony um deal where i
believe it was sacha who came out from
um microsoft on the corporate level with
for azure so servers you know she deals
primarily with game pass and these
yeah definitely on the gaming side so
what happened with game pass
because oh yeah
um
my man here
hello
oh that's nothing to do that's about
them cloud and mobile
then what happened
day and date what's going on here where
we at with this what we talking about
the sovereign i want you up next because
i want you to explain yourself the
congregation calls you up
[Music]
oh let's get it
oh no no cause he's he's
he's done
and then he's finished
his premium bars
now now as sonic peeps you
now what you got to say is remember i'll
let you talk
no no no hold on now
i get to do that
oh it's we need to deliver we delivered
on you
so you don't get to say oh i want golden
axe but let me let it i want it this way
but i never told you
i told you i wasn't going to give you
some of your flowers right as a matter
of fact when i went online i said let's
go i don't care about online i say
you're kidding
i said king is spinning half truths
right as you as you want as you tend to
do
all right
okay
i'm not gonna get interrupted am i okay
okay okay let's go solve you you get a
chance to rebut this
so
i have to admit right off the rip right
that's good as soon as i saw this
i was like motherflower [ __ ]
i fell for your brother the flower
so
off off the rip i'm gonna give you a
little a slight knee bend because oh
salute i'm gonna give you the ant that's
big again
i'm gonna give you that because we would
fight y'all fighting hard
that is
the deal that you have with satan right
now
like i i really i could not believe it i
was like i can't believe this is a
thing
can i ask you one question did your
heart sink a little bit with the jews
like i said when i said i i cursed this
man and i love this man to death now
curse this man
i cannot believe i have to address this
right
okay that's big for someone
i give you that event right no doubt no
doubt but then like i said as kings want
to do right he he'll take something
and twist
and manipulate and manipulate
to get it to fit a narrative right and
again if it fit perfectly in the
narrative i give it up completely no
doubt no doubt but it but it doesn't
because break it down any anybody who's
ever listened to me over the course of
four years on this podcast no talk your
talk
mind you when we talk about sega right i
think i was the first one to ever bring
up sega i remember four years ago
in our
um
what's it called uh the e3 prediction
series yes yes we had cow
yeah tim dawg
yes and i was like pie in the sky yeah
sega i remember yeah partner with sega
panda driver
right
so that's what i wanted right for me
it's the core ip that i want to see come
back in a real way right with real
partnership with xbox right yes yes so i
looked at this and i was like
just saying that right
it's not it guys i'm about to go oh i
got to get ever bored though too i don't
know
everybody's chomping right there
hold on let me finish this ain't it at
least on paper this is not it right can
it grow into that right and this is
another thing i need y'all to understand
let's get it
this is a knee i'm happy to bend if i'm
wrong okay i want this to be the case i
just don't think it is just yet because
of this reason right
if it were that
the language of this deal
would have expressed that right you had
sarah bond come out she didn't
specifically say anything about games
she spoke about the partnership she
spoke about creating this online
environment right creating in azure she
spoke about all that they didn't speak
about the games right okay
just
that's fine but that she spoke about her
love of dreamcast okay so for right now
it's still it's still light for you
until you see you need more fruit right
so check this out right so then i say i
said let's see what we've seen to date
right they could have led up to this
right well first of all we got streets
of rage game pass day one fantastic yeah
beautiful love that right mm-hmm
then we get
then we so we got age of empires
recently right mm-hmm
fantastic football manager football
manager is big right football manager's
big because that is a huge franchise
huge european yeah that is right
but when i look at those games right
when you and i think about sega and the
lego and king you think about the legacy
of sagan king stop posting that sonic
i'm feeling good do those do those games
come to mind
when you think about old
parrot
i don't like sonic rocking back and
forth
when you think about corsair
are you thinking about
football manager are we thinking about
football no no absolutely are we
thinking about
total hold on but i i have something for
your cruisers as well
are we thinking about total war
warhammer
all right i i got i got i got to deflect
on one day i gotta shoot on one part i
gotta defend you i'm looking at the
strategic portfolio right they have
their strategy one strategy two the
priority strategy for three years which
they consider their global strong ip the
list is sonic
fantasy star online tool which is on
game pass and i believe that was
exclusive
yakuza which debuted next gen
um on the series x first it will there
be a timed exclusive and then eventually
came to gay pass persona 5 which is not
there to your point which is not there
yet
and then we got total war so those are
the ips that they consider
it says strategy one making existing
existing eyepieces to go blind
establishment of strong ip which is
recognized as a global brand and those
when we say three fifths of those kind
of made it the ones the ones that fit
into game pass like we talked about
football manager all that stuff is
fantastic right because it fits into
what game pass does very well right yes
it gives them this broad audience that
they have not been getting in the game
now when you look let's look at yakuza
right
that is a series that was initially
launched on the playstation correct
remastered on the playstation correct in
some cases even remade on the
playstation
before it before it saw the light of day
on xbox right
before it saw the light of day on xbox
right
by the time he sees a lot of day on xbox
they already knew that the creative
director of this game
was two this man was negotiating to
leave sega in the past two years right
so when by the time this comes into game
pass
it's already moving on right so what do
they do they give you the experimental
one they give you the wonder where they
change up everything right right that's
our basement and
it was great fantastic it was fantastic
it's a huge moment right yes
that's not necessarily what they
expected right so you we got lucky with
that we got lucky but at the end of the
day they sold
to me the creative director of that
series is gone right judgment is a wrap
judgment is a rapture the action version
of this the action version of this is a
wrap
so
they sold you
a ticket
to a potentially sinking [ __ ] i'm just
telling you right now wow okay okay
and and i think like a dragon is great
but we don't know i got you everybody
right
total war
warhammer 40k that's not it
how many who anybody can make a
warhammer game okay
anybody
all you got to do is give them 40k then
40k they can make you can make a
warhammer game but who made the
warhammer game but it doesn't matter
it's on the sega banner right and and
someone over here quickly went on on
twitter
talking about warhammer 40k
like he plays one hammer
what is king doing
so my thing is this i can't
no you can't get it at the end of the
day
at the end of the day this is the main
thing i took away from this right all
the language talks about how they are
going to help sega improve their
development pipeline right right right
right all this azure they're going to
get all the hot azure pipe that they can
take
this is the funny part about it right
all of that is in service of making
persona 6
the best playstation 5 exclusive wow
it ain't coming to xbox oh
it ain't happening
they are not be holding it
just going down with the ship
so why is it so you guys in your heart
of hearts believe i believe persona four
golden will come next box and five
eventually okay but you just said he
won't go no no i said six oh
the new joint okay okay
so you still after all that used to with
four or five you still don't think six
what could you do no [ __ ] six ain't
coming damn date that's not happening no
don't do it that's not happening
and you got healthy
brother you've been avoided losing your
knees for long persona
[Laughter]
the last time i took my shades off
like jim ryan
your legs went all left and right and
you cursed my name
now you asked me what pack i got in
place
and who
am i talking to
phil dominus maximus aurelia spencer oh
god what is his name
first of his class
please kind sir
let's finish him off
yo
if he's
and listen listen
i don't want to hear nothing else but
the only thing is
like this is one of those those bending
knees where it would take so long right
for us to get fruition from the
development standpoint right
yeah but but the north remembers right
fine i have no i have no problems with
that okay
but i'm gonna tell you this right now
that game yeah does not launch day and
date with the playstation verse
wow all right i've been on it i'm in on
this one
nothing in the language of this deal
says anything about
games and actual i i p they're going to
be bringing to the xbox platform to the
xbox no no no no super games they didn't
say it was coming xbox
did they say it was coming to
you guys
basically you feel we're jumping the gun
we feel you feel we're jumping very
in the future i'm not saying i don't
want it to happen in the future but you
i'm just saying based on this
please that is not telling me that that
is happening
and i'm going to tell you what i need to
hear
we're going to get we're going to get
everybody
why is it
that everybody gets to drink from the
chalice before xbox does no i'm with you
i'm with you no everybody does right
everybody does when it comes to persona
ah playstation drinks from the challenge
i feel you listen when it comes to
bayonetta right ah nintendo drinks from
the chalice right by the time it gets by
the time it gets to xbox
chalice empty
look ev every listen oh i will say this
before i pass it everything and that's
when you buy the chalice right
but anyway everyone everything you said
to this point
every action and how things have
happened to this point
agreed right it has happened kind of in
the way that you state it
let me not talk because it's really not
my time um everyone please
okay see here's the thing that happens
sometimes inside you know i love you
you know you gotta hurt your bed we
gotta tell a friend right
right just this is like
this year coming out of his eyes new
black city but the thing is this
um
sometimes people do they they walk into
the valley of the shadow of death
and they don't realize they're already
surrounded until it's too late
they they continue see and i said this i
talked about this on the gaming circle
podcast check out k asante's channel we
talked about this in depth yesterday
because que asante is another sega
doubter right so i said stop that is
taking that carrot
what's that no saul's not a sega doubter
though he's not it he he loves him i
don't mean sega but this deal
now the thing is this
the carrot in front of everyone
is persona yes but by the time you see
persona happen it's already too late
you're surrounded
the the archers bows are trained on you
already you can't escape
right and whatever let me ask you this
though everborn yes sir all the archers
that are surrounding you right
they're not surrounding me they're
surrounding you but okay but all the
oranges are surrounding me right
age of empires three
six sega franchise another classic sega
franchise warhammer 40k
when i talk about an empty chalice this
is what they're giving you they're
giving you the backwash you're getting
backwashed this is what you watch
and then i don't want to hear that
microsoft got to build up to us why does
anybody else not have to build up but
they are american companies it doesn't
matter
it's not it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter they have all the money no it
does not see these rules they put them
down it does not matter so all of a
sudden now but
the same argument can be made in the
other direction
all of a sudden have all the money in
the world they can do whatever they want
but this can't happen because they have
to specifically butter them up a
specific way in order to get this to
happen
listen it's not every date you go on
where you could just take into
mcdonald's and seal the deal
sometimes you have to you gotta you
gotta work on it right you gotta you
gotta call them you gotta you you know
you gotta have conversations you gotta
pretend like you're friends and things
like that i'm gonna tell you this in
like her jokes are funny this is what's
gonna happen right phil phil's gonna
come over he's gonna put his arm around
sega and he's gonna he's gonna whisper
persona mm-hmm
and they're gonna
turn around look at him and they're
gonna forget how to speak english wow
persona
[Laughter]
this is a sugar daddy move where they
they spent all this they they spent this
money to be in this partnership right
and at the end of the day
they can spend all the money they want
you think it's never going to change
that relationship but if they want to
get past first base
you got to dish out more you got to dish
out more you got to shop more
and for me for them to get there
see the thing the wording of this
agreement yes none of it makes them
beholden to xbox in any way
they are paying for a service they're
getting that service and beyond that
everything is theoretical everything is
people assuming where it's gonna go no
no no no no but see this is where you're
wrong
this is it this is what i'm saying right
when you you know how
when you look at a stock by the time you
hear about it on cnbc all the gains to
be had are gone it's already people
right right so so what i'm saying is you
can't look at
persona that's the big fish where
everyone will understand it see right
now if if you look at the moves that
sega is making as it relates to
microsoft listen i saw the writing on
the wall with that cobalt blue
controller
right now the thing is this
they are
systematically taking
all they they can't first of all they
can't stop talking about how good game
pass has been for them am i am i right
or am i right right they have they keep
talking
so
uh you know they were drowning and then
here comes the life rafters game pass
comes to save them right right so now we
see
we see certain little next gen exclusive
exclusivity with yakuza then the whole
yakuza franchise is on there now now now
like a dragon is in game pass as well
right
we see this warhammer 40k we see that
that that they worked on age of empires
for 82 metacritic right to go do that
what was it they they got a relic was
that yeah or was that creative assembly
which one that was linked to
creative assembly did halo wars too yes
okay so the point is
slowly but surely they are positioning
all of these moves and they're they're
so ingrained in the microsoft ecosystem
right and and we can we can take aside
the fact that it doesn't get more
organic than this for when they
eventually acquire them by the end of
the generation right but before we we
don't even have to get there right
it is
i don't think
that microsoft could walk in and i know
you said not to say this but i'm saying
it anyway you don't just walk in for
that kind of a deal and say i'm throwing
my money around uh now let me go
motorboat some things right you have
to you have to you have to whine and die
so when the time comes for you to make
the case to seal the deal it's already
too late and it is not just the the the
sony microsoft thing because that was
this that was the ceo of all of sega
sammy and the ceo of all of microsoft
correct this deal was specifically the
ceo president and ceo of sega and sarah
bond who's responsible for making things
happen like this right right you didn't
satya nadella didn't even tweet about
this yet right right so this is an xbox
situation and more and more sega
has been and will continue to as
exampled by warhammer and the next thing
will will happen and the next thing will
happen and we'll see they're they're
pushing more of their ip and this is top
tier for sega today we can't say um
where's altered beast or shinobi because
they don't have altar beast or shinobi
today right so at what point is it for
you right sovereign where you will
reckon that's what i'm going to say like
if you're going to be personal yeah it
it's it'll already be too late
they will already be so embedded and
again just remember this last thing that
i will say
the the important thing to me here how
you know it's not just a cloud deal they
said development environment yeah and
the last time they got in bed with
microsoft
for development to use their whole
development environment was the
dreamcast which is the greatest council
of all time
i would fight to death on that but again
again
the the storied relationship that they
that they have had over the years
because remember um and we talked about
this there was a time when sega first
left the console business that they were
doing a lot of exclusives with with xbox
right right and it's really only persona
and i think virtual fighter 5 that the
and i guess bayonetta that that they
haven't given out but everything else
they've done the xbox has been on so
it's just those three titles that we're
where we're fooling ourselves into
thinking that they are not what this is
not one of the most close um publisher
platform holder relationships in the
industry right now
right it's just those three games and
they will come i think that's more of uh
maybe it's more of an atlas thing i
don't know maybe atlas just hates the
xbox so they only have um um knowledge
knowledge base to work on on um and i
got to get acg in this yeah right but
again like i said if you're waiting for
uh persona and bayonetta it's already
too late you can see the moves that they
are making that they're putting all of
their ip
in game pass or in conjunction there's
they are developing games for microsoft
microsoft is giving them technology
again we're talking about development
environments as well
like i don't really know what else we
need to see if you like i said you can
wait until the press release for persona
comes out
but by then they'll be so closely
embedded the the next day you'll hear
about the acquisition but that's my
thought song okay oh i gotta get acg in
because yeah i know sav you want to read
but i know i was invited acg's been
super patient and i'm dying to know what
he feels about this uh microsoft and
sega strategic alliance
yeah sovereign's for sure right
thank you there's
that this is
i don't know if people so
the the what sega is saying and what
microsoft is saying it for sure can lead
to any game coming because that's the
way games i mean look at what happened
with um
starfield where sony was looking for
exclusivity right up until the moment
microsoft bought bethesda right so this
stuff can change but what i saw what
i've read by the way you guys kept
saying age of empires it's not a sega ip
okay there you go no it's a microsoft
diapeda sega
yeah and it's since 2001 that's been a
microsoft thing so i don't you guys
might be talking about warhammer
warhammer
yeah but age of empires is like one of
my favorite games of all time that's
creative assembly that's so that kind of
stuff is
really neither here nor there what
sovereign was saying about sega
like honestly microsoft always getting a
little bit of the hind tit and that's a
dog reference not a
is that um there he is right and that is
something that microsoft has talked
about um there's some books that written
by a sega ceo that taught um tom
kolansky yeah he wrote about it as well
and and of course where microsoft got
laughed out of an actual like office
meeting with sony at times now sony or
sega i'm sorry sega is having issues
lately they've been trying to adjust
things so i would love to be wrong on
all this but i don't see anything in
that that doesn't indicate a couple
things and i tweeted the moment i saw it
which is number one emulation across
dreamcast most likely going exclusive to
microsoft so
that would be my first guess is that
we'll see some kind of dreamcast
cloud
infrastructure where it won't be a
physical thing it might be emulation of
dreamcast games which i would be man
ecstatic for like
so many of those
from what i've seen
it is true that sony and sega just have
a closer
their ips that are special just have
a sony slant they just do they that's
just where they go and um we did get
like a dragon which is a huge bonus but
i do agree with sovereign that we have
seen this and if you look back in prior
by the way sega sega and sony have both
done little things where they give a
little to somebody but it's always
second tier or third tier and i'm not
saying
that was second or third tier but it
wasn't the main one right and
i don't know about any of this stuff
bayonetta i don't know if i would
consider that like a huge
i mean it's a get but i don't know if i
would be like oh my god
um the stuff that you've got you said
three fifths of them are already on xbox
and i think that's true
i think that so sega is definitely open
on doing stuff
but when you look at what sega says
their prime ips are right
i don't know if those are the prime ips
that i think of and so when i see this
kind of stuff i'm like okay that's cool
but i don't i just don't see persona
i mean if it if it happens
which could happen by the way i mean
obviously anything can happen
yeah if it does happen i i have no issue
being wrong but i from what i've seen
and when reading that that is a cloud
thing
and it's also something that sega was
very clear because that's what i used to
do was write
contracts right and sega's pretty clear
in their announcement that
it was for them
and
sony also uses
microsoft and
those i agree with what you guys who
went out who came out i'm sure microsoft
wants all this stuff oh for sure i'm
sure
um and microsoft's doing well this year
or this not this year but this jen
they're doing well so uh i could be
wrong but what i read at least from that
announcement did not seem to indicate we
would see
day and date for their big titles if we
do
i would love to be wrong right because i
i think people would love to see of
course of course
on xbox i just don't um there's
something about them guys i don't know
how to describe it there's something
about particular sony and sega stuff
where it just feels like it's always
going to be sony so to be wrong and have
that pattern change i would gladly i
mean i think we'll all be let me jump in
this is great this is great i love this
um
here's a dick you know everyone i hear
you coming from acg makes some fantastic
place trust me i do hear where you're
coming from
y'all know me
normally i am the most conservative this
is nothing burger
kind of a guy until i see
speci i need to see very specific things
the reason why for the first time
in a long time i have i am leaning
king's direction
is because when i looked at the sony
deal right
it said they are forming
a partnership
right and like everborn said you know
there was an exchange there is okay we
are here's our azure backbone
here's our what is it sensors or
something to that effect
and this is what we're doing and then
the optics of it
is satya nadella and then obviously you
know sony
the the sarah bond thing is key for me
that is one that's one aspect of it
right because she's in the xbox division
she's dealing primarily with games and
stuff like that so at its core yes right
now there is nothing saying
this is going to all sega games are
exclusive i am not there right i am with
y'all on that to the letter of the law
what this does not say that
however there are tea leaves that to me
indicate a bigger thing and the key for
me is and i want to shout out um ksi
until your boy um
he's on obviously protein you guys do on
the real stuff like that
the the verbiage
because they used in the sony deal
partnership
this is a strategic alliance a strategy
is different rather than a single per
i'm going to read it single purpose
partnership alliance is a form to
combine the resources of two companies
across a range of complementary skills
set or other assets while a alliances
may be established with a specific
outcome in mind the spirit of most
alliances is to reimagine and recombine
whatever the two partners are good at
individually to address evolving
business opportunities they couldn't
tackle alone and what exactly does sega
have to offer microsoft that's what i'm
saying to me the value is to get here's
the key when i look at their strategic
portfolio right they got their key
strategies sega sammy this is what they
want to do one marketing existing ips
into a global brand the five that they
consider sonic fantasy star on line two
um yakuza total war episode five we
already went into that what i feel as
far as some of those games there but the
other thing is super game
that to me is the key supersonic
creation i don't know where you're going
i'm not going there but the creation of
super game to me
represents
this online
cloud infrastructure based game right or
a series of games we're hearing projects
of like that we're hearing right because
they they called it an initiative and
then it's
right right and here's the to me i look
at the tea leaves with remember fantasy
star online two right given exclusive
cloud if they're they're raving about
how they left i believe the average
amazon aws backbone and then went to
azure and it's it's oh my god they can't
stop yelling about this right so at
first what i just thought it was just
that
and then i see super game and i'm like
okay you guys got big visions and the
other key again indicator for me that
something more may be happening
is when i look at the kojima situation
and i look about this quote-unquote
letter of intent and what he intends and
we know death stranding had the little
aspects of cloud and everything and then
we do know he had a deal so allegedly
with um google stadia to make this
cloud-based game so when i hear that to
me this is another direction that i feel
sega wants to get it and the last point
i'll say
is um
they talk about expansion of past ip uh
libraries support subscription
utilization of past ips
we just saw with nintendo in their
expansion pass too one thing that was
very striking to me
was to see the sega genesis controller
to see their titles their ips their all
this initiative being pumped into
you know on the nintendo's online image
i thought that was very big for i'm like
wow that's that's the kind of i would
say sacrilegious but i was like i've
never seen that from saying it's weird
yeah that's weird like like you just
you're giving them the branding and so
again
to to acc i hear you guys i hear you
solve i actually agree with you on your
big super game i'm just saying i i'm not
seen yeah no i know i know
as of right now right
there is nothing in this deal in this
language that says exclusive all games
are going next i get you but i am with
kig and everboy that the tea leaves are
in place
and that this probably most likely but
we'll develop it this there's an old
warren buffett quote let's go be brave
when everyone is scared and be scared
when everyone is brave
right
now right now
sav
and acg they're scared
i know i know you know the xbox faithful
they're used to you know getting the
drags i get it you know
and and i know and i know
and i know y'all get excited for any
little thing that's why you know king
runs out there in the middle of the
night in his drawers
i'm happy to bend the knee when this is
real okay but it's not real yet and
there's nothing here that indicates that
it's real in a real way and then the ips
you guys are talking about let's be real
let's be real the guy the core guys on
this panel are y'all playing those games
no but sorry all right i got to come at
you son and i love you i love you
brother brother i love you no no let me
get this one borrowed but i'm not i'm
not no no listen you're right you're
right i'm not discounting their
importance right but that's
not discounting their importance what
i'm talking about what i'm talking about
is when and i specifically said yeah
what what
what the sega deal would mean for me
right and i meant to get you the game
so this
that does nothing for you
i'm with you
it's all about improving sega right
because again there's no if listen if
there was more to this deal and i know i
know there was more language in the deal
that talked about remakes and rematches
they talked about great that's the stuff
i'd love to see fantastic right
there's no language in this deal that
indicates that any of that that's going
to be happening as a result of this
improved development environment
is going to have any preference on the
xbox platform all right but so fantasy
start wait wait hold on so fantasy star
online two
their new mmo game
they were exclusive right but this is
the thing
fantasy star online to
new genesis is essentially a new game
right right
they they just they they built a new
game for whatever reason
on the online to get the online for
whatever reason do it on game pass
initially great right right how many
people playing that game now
that matters
how many games gotta come to game fast
before we realize well my thing is this
but this is my thing right when i when i
talk about strong franchises right yeah
ah what bothers me is y'all capping
about stuff that y'all know is not
important to this whole post move that
you're doing here there's no goal post
movie you're all right about stuff
remember remember remember let me ask
you something is it like last week or a
week before he said y'all be stupid
enough to fall for his
stuff
and this is what he i'm not even gonna
insult your intelligence because you're
looking right through him right now like
you're seeing him and y'all remember
when he said
i don't need them to buy sega i just
need them to form something like
alliance
that was your own words your own words
did you and that was what they did and
this ain't it
i would have to disagree and say this
isn't it but regardless of all this
here's the thing those games are great
i'm honestly one of the problems
microsoft has is pr i love microsoft pr
they're very nice yes but they
they don't always grab the gamer by the
spine like sony has we would
so here's what would have blown me away
first of all bill spencer in that
meeting as well though i believe sarah
bond being there makes total sense if he
had been there would have slightly
changed additionally if they had said
panzer dragon order saga too
the oldest pc or the average pc gamer by
the way just just tracked 38 years old
that's crazy yeah sega has this long
history oh yeah
and
that's what
microsoft needs microsoft does not
do well on that one particular thing and
that is what would fire me up i agree
that all this stuff is awesome
and persona's bigger
but dude something would happen to
gamers where i could say i could talk
like i could talk of panzer dragon saga
like other people talk of final final
fantasy
exactly and currently microsoft does not
have that
i got one kind of point and i feel which
i said but this is the part i gotta
agree with king though it's like it's
almost
you know as gamers we are hardcore
gamers right
and we love what we love right but like
there is a zeitgeist of games that we
don't care about that are actually
bigger than the games we love
you know and that's what personally like
one of them i like it
what i'm trying to say is i don't want
to minimize when i see a football
manager i don't want to like that for
sure is humong in the fact it's
launching day and date
game pack that is a huge but that's
because what that's what game pass does
well like it would be
like that that doesn't know i just told
you i'm not minimizing okay i'm just i
just told you i'm not minimizing it
what's happening here is this this is a
guy trying to talk his way out of this
bullet i'm not trying to talk right this
is why i already told you i bend the
knees
i don't want that you don't want that
i'm i'm going i'm going for the kill now
i'm
you understand like when you got the the
the situation trained on the dude and
he's sitting there like i didn't mean to
touch that stuff like that because i
basically just
stop stop with the analogies and get to
the point
you had a chance to do all that crazy
stuff i'm gonna get to do me
so listen
he said out of his own words if you go
back and look at the tape
where's the tape why did you bring it on
you don't need them to buy them
yeah you just need a partnership or an
alliance that offers me what i wonder of
your word
no don't stop talking no
because for me we can have king's world
we can have addict's world king could
maneuver anything he wants the way he
wants everything he specifically said so
let's be clear let's be clear i have to
tell them so let's wait wait let's be
let's be clear let's be clear what is
this
little bro you can love what you love my
question is i'm sorry i'm sorry i just
because we got to nail this part
otherwise we can't argue
what
is it that has to happen
for you to say
that this is an official story one core
sega
stay specific you gotta stay specific i
want streets of rage i want panda
dragoon okay
i want shinobi i want all of those
things to come back as core games core
so they have to be a new ip i don't i
don't want any free to play i don't want
i don't want none of that stuff
we'll go
fine and i admitted that did i not say
that
i'm even less of a desire i don't even
need the core i just that language
would need to state right like what you
need they're diving into combined
development on
we could all be wrong because contract
yeah and writing sucks yeah absolutely i
mean admittedly but that's what i would
want i mean i don't even need the co i
love panzer dragon i just wish it was a
little bit more solid so we could go
because here's the thing sony would do
that sony would put a font
it would be a font made in photoshop
yeah it's exclusive
exclusive yeah you ain't getting it
you're anybody
so when microsoft doesn't say that you
know it's not there all right but hold
on but this way i disagree i got to give
it back to my boy everboy
i still feel
to your point i see what y'all said
trust me i see what y'all said
to you going on here no but bro but bro
you gotta admit they don't have it's a
japanese company with another japanese
company this is an american company
there are different protocols here and
there is a a nurturing that has to
happen before you know
what's happening 40 years what nurturing
has to happen all right all right solve
stop stop now i got to come for you now
sorry what nurturing bro they wouldn't
they were part of sacred samurai they
could even be acquired until they got
rid of the particular division
come on let's be honest
like we're we are accustomed to
getting data and when it doesn't come in
for microsoft you have to slate on the
negative side because it's been negative
forever absolutely absolutely i just
wish
i just think that
if i was microsoft for instance and it
was games i would be like sega please
just let us say it's games because we
would kill christmas because the honest
truth is already killing christmas at
least from what i can tell right they're
the ones who are nailing this last fall
right
if i wanted to nail fall big time i'd be
like oh by the way if you're not a
flight simulator fan if you're not a
forza fan if you're not a halo fan then
i would go through all the games that
were out maybe you're a sega fan because
guess what's coming
it means vr but none of that's happened
and so that's why we skew negative
because it just
right but when those when those core
franchises happen
when it happens in five years i will
bend the knee listen listen this is the
craziest thing
i agree with that yeah i'm a tr you just
think there's more no no no no no no no
no well you activated your part is more
i'm a troll
yes we thank you sir thank you speaker
speaker
i'm a troll
you said
a strategic yeah you hold it up to last
week
you're keeping his feet on this fire i
see what you're doing
um until you play that back it didn't
happen right okay
this is
your persona 6.
you're done son wait so don't worry do
we have to bend the knee do we have we
already did that
no we're bending me is called sega
franchises right yes no no no no no no
do we have bentley
i'm
so wait what are the terms the terms are
if persona 6 is announced
and it is said to come also on the xbox
platform at the same time day and day no
later and this is not even the gamepad
this is just day and day when they
announced multi-plat across the board
you get at the same time that is the
bending the
official gladly
so this is my only part with this whole
segment yeah it really don't have
nothing to do with all this stuff and i
need to have none of that i don't care
about that
you know what you said
and what happened
now the last time i took off my shades
and he asked for something very specific
it came
to pass
you're done
thank you
thank you thank you so much we got it we
got to move we got to do this
we've established the terms this is this
is this is how you keep the knees on
nice keep the need this may be your wife
but keep the knees on ice
[Music]
gonna be
she's going to announce all of those ips
and then she's going to say for the
watch
if it comes out one day later on xbox he
loses
absolutely
absolutely absolutely
he's gonna do like boom he's gonna call
me on the phone
acg is gonna link me
in the tweet when it happens oh first
put the eyes and he's going to say when
is that statue of you coming
i'll do that
look this is a good one i love the
passion great discussion guys
i know how he does all right what's
their bed
it's not persona 6 it's the next
mainline persona rpg because if they do
no because they decide to do student
persona legacy
i see what you're saying no legacy or
persona strikers here's the thing though
guys i think he is he's onto something
because if it's persona strikers that is
not the same thing right now i think but
we all agree it's personal
you just don't want to jump out the
window if like persona 5 right royale
comes out
no strikers
no doubt this is fantastic
let's read this which
i like how everborn talks like an author
and it speaks he speaks
absolutely
[Laughter]
this was a phenomenal episode i'm
literally going to just speedball this
last time because it's really quick yeah
i just want your thoughts and then we
get everybody on it because this was
crazy episode today um look g4 is now
out here snitching again
oh yeah what's going on y'all geforce
now 2.0 looks like um shout out to comic
games so like they put some stuff out
there and reference that look this list
is long um
goes to sashima pc
2022
they have some dates hogwarts legacy
hollow hollow knight sucks long
fraternal pc avowed kingdom hearts is on
this list fables on those lists crisis
for
you know the list is humongous mk12
black with wukong dragon h4
so again you know the the thought is
that there are some more leaks going on
as far as pc ports xbox playstation
playstation pc all this stuff you know
what do you guys think about these leaks
you know there is also a rumor obviously
that um some of these are not definitive
and more placeholder kind of stuff so um
hcg i see you ready to jump let's get
right to it man what are you thinking
about yeah it's just i would i think a
lot of those are real but i do think
when you see fable we don't know the
name you know some of those are just
names but yeah a lot of those are real
and the companies you know pre they'll
be asked like what games do you have
working you know blah blah i will tell
you that this will be closed very
quickly somebody will figure out how to
close the scene so it doesn't continue
happening oh no i can guarantee you
right now people are coding going this
can never happen again what do we do um
but yeah i think all those you know we
saw a lot of a lot of leaks that have
come true from the past one and um we've
got you know things like sony obviously
you know some of their titles and now
we're seeing those announcements finally
got a war without looking out of a
vagina
so i'm so excited uh dude to me it's
more people i don't want to get into the
what platform gets de-monetized or what
or gets lowered because of it i'm just
really excited
really excited for all those i saw there
wasn't a lot of surprises though i will
say i would on that list i didn't go
what i mean is there wasn't a leak of a
new game we hadn't heard of yes yeah
does that make sense absolutely
absolutely ever born the leaks man who's
snitching do you believe it placeholders
well yeah
um i mean you
i want to say yes i believe it but were
there any more playstation games on that
list oh yes ghost oh yeah ghosts yeah
ghost is on there final fantasy 7 remake
pc
comes out for the pc and it don't hit
the xbox that's huge i'm going to flip
my desk yeah i'll be here
that'd be huge placeholder date is uh
june 1st 2022
so no but um i i yeah i mean i it it
sounds about right and i mean i think i
think we're gonna see um
more of the
who knows when day and date will happen
although i think it will happen but i do
think um
all
you know all of their mainline ip i
think is working really well for them
right now
uh
you know
they've got their initial release i
think they're building towards a day and
date and they'll get there before the
end of the generation but i do think all
of their all the things that people said
were never going to come to pc uh will
come to pc so the list the list makes
sense to me no doubt no doubt you know
what i've where we at bro we think of
this um
yeah you think the snitching
in the in this case where there's smoke
that's fine
this is the kind of thing he wants to
see
this is what i want to see the world
from
everybody solid
and i got to shout out my man king cause
we together we've been we've been saying
this for a long time it's like it's just
gonna happen i need to get used to this
exactly and i i see demon souls on this
list and i think the most interesting
thing i see
is back to the clank and and i see i
didn't know he stayed yeah he released
it
[Music]
six months removed from this launch are
you implied that the time for
playstation pcs are getting reports
getting less and less as lord
said so eloquently
uh
yeah i i think that that timeline is
drinking and drinking and drinking and
drinking
and the convergence is upon us it's upon
us it is upon us
again
you see you see how we could be arguing
once that's why i love you
that's what that's we're brothers we can
fight go to fidel and then they're gonna
laugh and enjoy each other but when you
look at when you you see gt7
you see okay
yes can i ask you something sovereign
sure so we don't
sideline it gt7 has a hard time on pc
because pc is the sim racer community
yes if that game comes out on pc it
better deliver because those guys if
you've ever looked at a review for sim
racing holy they're like the hairpin
turn is approximately 2.1 degrees off
and you're just like dude that's going
into a harsh environment so i'm i just
want to say i'm excited for that but i
was surprised the most at seeing that on
the list right yeah there are flight sim
guys on pc that actually put on
the the the pilot's outfit and come in
with the brief suitcase oh yeah man
right they're cosplaying a pilot yeah
yeah yeah all right go ahead
no no man like you're absolutely right
um but i think
i think the money they're gonna make
yeah
allows them to be willing to take
whatever smoke they're gonna get from
the hardcore community because that's
fine you're gonna get that anyway
because you have those enthusiasts that
are really you know they they sort of
tune every single one of their cars and
it has to be exactly the same way you've
had people who've learned to drive and
won races with gran turismo so
for me all of this is true some of the
names might be placeholders but you
don't put a random you don't put what
the heck was the
one that they put like a four in front
of uh it was it was a something four
yeah there was no stuff in there jesus
and you don't put that there unless you
have some crisis for kingdom hearts
kingdom hearts
you foreign put that there unless you
have some inkling of what's coming yeah
just don't do that so
even if the names aren't what it is
right
damn near everything here is real some
of the stuff might never see the light
of day
but whatever that's development stuff
yeah do i think at this moment
that stuff exists in some way shape or
form 100
is dragon's dogma 2 still on there i
believe so i hope so i god i oh my lord
that is the one time you will see me
maybe pass a game
because that game i am a
it is crap i've reviewed that game on
four platforms like at some point you
should run out of [ __ ] to say so like
that is i can't wait man yeah
it wasn't wasn't the switch was the
switch version even like great yeah i
played and reviewed it yeah he's just a
super fan yeah that's cool yeah this is
this is
just get ready
get ready
laura king final thoughts on this thing
man
all i had to say was ratchet and clang
yeah
right cause i told dudes and they wasn't
listening to me ssd king
and they asked me or what game do i
think would be the next game that's
coming out and i said ratchet and clank
and it was like oh no no that this isn't
possible nothing why did i get out of
that voice it's not just
crazy if teleporting is possible in a
game that is possible sorry yeah yeah
[Music]
and we see it in a ton of games it's
coming out um young guys got sold uh
botalized
and and you took it
and it's
okay because
of lions
microsoft already told you we sold out
so when the list came out
it was overlooked see this is what
happens when you take the slings and the
arrows first
you already got those arrows in you
walking past you looking at the dude
with the new arrows
and sony got the new arrows those some
new arrows all right so when you're
going down the list and you say demon
souls and stuff oh i thought that was on
one play
i thought it was only the power of the
five
the fast ssd you fell for
cuddling the playstation 5 against his
chest when he talks
[Laughter]
like that
the wildest thing is y'all fell for
everything they said and it was all
alive
and now now now the chickens come home
to roost and you'll see the situation
for what it is and i understand y'all
may be heartbroken at this moment
you do because you know how they do they
make spaces and they go in and they talk
about how the games that they wasn't
going to support anyway
but you got a powerful pc anyway so you
should be happy
it could be better than the playstation
5 right so at no point in time should
you be upset with anything that's
transpiring right for your eyes because
you did this to yourself you don't you
dealt in absolutes now you're absolutely
heartbroken
yo
bars
those are bars you know what though like
serious note though and this is the
thing
jokes aside
like
how many times do people have to
get spoon-fed talking points run with
them as though they are fact
only to be turned around and it'd be the
exact opposite and then we can't have
adult conversations about the
because my thing is one thing to say you
speculate you don't believe it won't
never happen but when it does happen
don't go post move or do what about ism
god falls exclusive to ps5
remember that and you know say it again
it's just it's just and the same goes
for saab with sega but yeah
oh me too i i sort of said something how
y'all doing be nice but
i didn't move a goal no but one thing
about song though the difference is
regardless of what happened everyone on
this panel right or wrong
we will admit to the other one yo and
probably celebrate yeah
yeah i will be the first one in the
street to celebrate yeah you'll be
you're going to be the house
if this turns into an acquisition yeah
it will we we've talked about that
whatever
and i do this all the time it is like
it's this mental gymnastics that i do
where i speak uh outwardly against
something because i know i have bad luck
actually happened
no with me i don't have that ultimate
i'm the ultimate devil's advocate like
if you look at how i answer questions
here
i'm always putting myself in in the
other person's shoes right because a lot
of times we talk about things and
how we perceive it in our bubble right
right right and yeah oftentimes
good point kind of objectively about
stuff right especially on a podcast
right you want to be able to understand
the other side of the art absolutely so
for me selfish me
you're selfish but you you're
self-resolving happy as hell if this
happened exactly
but but like
the the me that questions everything is
just like why did like acg said why
didn't you just say it like seeing the
game you know why though i think on a
bigger to get away from the he shed he
said she said i think the biggest thing
is we all just there's some clarity that
we're getting really tired of not just
yeah
that's right
dude since the atari like i'm tired of
somebody coming out and being like this
is exclusive and every single person is
like for how long you're right right
yeah
and yeah you're making it so sorry i
just want to say make it if it's going
to be expensive undeniably whatever
unquestionable make it yeah make it
unquestionable but also make it make it
an offering why
is it exclusive like
something tangible and i know people
will be really mad about that but what
i'm saying is i think if they can't do
that they will stop stop saying it and
we will get back to just being honest
insane we're showing it right now but
yeah it's on everything yeah with the
level of transparency they've had till
now i'm like damn if that is the point
say it bro i'm with you and to your
point the only re the only thing i will
say where i finally saw the difference
is the bethesda deal
because when the starfield situation
came out it did take a while and
remember i was on their head too i was
like if y'all don't just say this
because what the hell is going on you
know what i'm saying and it annoyed me
and i'm like stop being nice
yeah because i'm like at the end of the
day dumb your competition ain't playing
nice with you that they are that's
another thing you're right yeah
let's be honest
you said it best i'll give it right back
to you everybody you said it best if
sony's nurturing that relationship
oh you gonna see plastered all over the
billboards the box art you ain't getting
it with us
that's right
not for you that's what it's gonna say
but again uh like bruce wayne in the end
of uh
the writer i love it right let's go he
came in and said how did you get my
house back
i bought the bank
right so so so again
we can say like there there were people
you know people doubted the bethesda
thing why don't they say anything why
don't they say anything
but ultimately where's starfield coming
i forgot
right so let me ask you this
do you think like um
like so for this to happen do you think
for honestly for me
like for this to really happen i i
i would see microsoft being like you
know what don't pay us anything
yeah we're gonna we're gonna hook you up
with azure don't pay us anything
i mean that's how you wind them down
them right like if you really want to
that's not how business works yeah i get
that i get that but if you're talking
about how difficult it is for them to
even get in bed with these guys and get
and get the conversation going right
if you really want to make that boss
move be like you know we got you don't
worry we'll talk about terms later we'll
talk about the terms later i understand
that's not how business works no
question because we we seem to
double back yeah we got this thing again
right we're back at it again
and um i just want to ask a question
right
who's the market leader
playstation
who the hell would you do business with
playstation
thank you
now
why are they doing when they are no
longer the market leader
and when those numbers do come out for
game pass and you give me needs for that
too
that too when did i offer up these for
that
oh no because that that means the 30
would have to be this is real it's real
it's not real it's real
we're diverted let's just focus
i just want to say this one
when
they are no longer the market leader you
would see people treat them differently
when the 360 was in its heyday
they treated
microsoft all right so we got to get
back to that you know you you forget
somebody else was in charge and messed
everything up and my man had to come and
fix everything yeah but remember now
you got a lot of good people in position
but the difference is that they're
playing different games now so the
one-to-one comparison isn't even there
anymore so that you're always going to
have the argument who's who's in the
lead right
as so if sony continues to sell consoles
hand over fist they can claim they're
winning right microsoft can have however
many game passes that's how you spend
the data it's very but it was right and
now now it's more spinnable than ever
because just playing two different games
right right right
i know
we
no but listen listen both sides
tremendous points we have to wait and
see episode 300 of iop is going to be
lit everything's 3 000 of us need to be
back on 9000 yeah
look we gotta go we gotta go we gotta
get the full question and we gotta go
didn't you get the switch and let me get
the poll we got to go this is a crazy
episode of fire though with the recent
exceptional reviews of forza horizon 5
on open critic and metacritic do you
think a racing game should be in
contention we answered that yes but we
gotta bring it to the room
oh yeah this is for the people because
they got a vote they got to vote this is
not for us this is this is funny i
apologize now you're good brother you're
good you're good do you think a race
game should be a potential for game of
the year at the game awards choices are
a no racy game should have their own
category like multiplayer games since
they are lacking major narrative
component
b
yes quality games must be respected
regardless of genre if a racing game
redefines the genre then it should be
considered for a nomination or c
i don't care about game of the year i
thought xbox had no games though so
salute to that guy who's being messy you
know those are gonna be the votes please
rock that at the end of the video
yo first of all salute
lord
acg the legend thanks for having me
pulling up man hanging out it's been
long overdue where can i find people
find you what do you have going on sir
acg now on youtube i always forget that
i have the old custom youtube yeah you
get the custom url and you'll be seeing
some reviews for some pretty big games
coming up but they're all under nda and
uh some other stuff from me but yeah i
just want to thank you guys it's always
a blast always hilarious stuff bro it
was so much fun we could talk for hours
you know how we do
it always a pleasure man absolutely
hilarious please salute and of course we
have the legend bronx's own my man i'm
here
stand up let's go what do you got going
on sir talk to him oh man we're just
trying to we're trying to get this uh
campaign over the top we hit a thousand
dollars live on air like we're actually
beautiful awesome since we started uh i
i keep the the
the
the minimum very low so i think we're
going for 3 000 on this one and that's
just going to cover uh printing and
fulfillment and things like that but the
book is already done it's already funded
and every campaign that i do i fund the
book first because i want to make sure
everybody gets it and it's no uh yeah
bro you are let me salute you on that
because you are so
meticulous you know just making sure
like i remember i see my cop my joy cave
is suited like you are so on board with
that as far as your transparency and
making sure people are clear with what
they're getting so salute to you for
that and fulfilling those promises i
love that about you
so yeah it's only going to go further
from here so it's this one now and then
we are gonna actually uh finally launch
the novel and we're adapting it also
as a
as a as a comic just like this one so
we're gonna launch the novel and the
comic adaptation side by side but the
comic adaptation will be like the first
chapter because it it takes almost like
10 grand to build one of these books
that's pretty crazy so um but yeah
that's coming in like uh the beginning
of q2 next year so we want we want to
get this one over the board and then
move the next one and then we have all
four of our series and that's our
foundation to move forward and tell this
story the way we want to do it no doubt
brother and look man salute to you
please support the everborn saga we got
the links in the chat please go out
there and support his brother he is he's
a content creator he is making things
happen outstanding art style and also uh
everyone look if you ever do them
audiobooks man i think acg and king
would be great on that absolutely
awesome absolutely that segment was lit
alone them narrating their own story was
great
scar every child in america
i need acg king that race karma
[Laughter]
calling during the podcast to tell me
some insignificant stuff salute him i
still don't know he told me to copy i
can't even he said he did it whatever
you did you did it i didn't do anything
okay he said he got it so whatever he
wanted he got for salute to him man he's
out here making it happen lord
feisty in the room i shaking orders
everybody first time you went up against
each other it's been a minute we really
usually agree man
sometimes you know i know how you do you
got to be the hype man i get that
i was like i said and when you brought
in hcg i was like yes he's on my side
some things might be strategic something
yeah yeah exactly you know thank you
some people didn't want to buy amazon
and google stock at first and now
a thousand dollars a share
just follow shaq that dude apparently
has of of all the people shaq apparently
has esp for stocks so just follow him so
what's good let's get his opinion on the
second doubt so yeah
catch me um actually i have an awesome
interview um that i'm about to do in
about an hour king knows what i'm
talking about
he knows what i'm talking about
exclusive exclusive it's exclusive
you definitely talk about it yeah my man
mr real nonstop talent already sat down
to speak with the king he's going to sit
down and talk with the sovereignty a
little bit um that's going to be very
cool um yeah uh you're going to catch me
trying to finish metroid damn it and and
play some more um
some forza horizon 5 because that game
is absolutely gorgeous big big shout out
to carrick for coming through oh yeah
yeah
and of cour everborn man my brother you
know bx love man like everything that
you're doing i felt so happy like every
time you put up a picture of you
at comic con when he was at comic con
i was like with your booth
yeah man like it's the first time as a
vendor i always go every year as a fan
yeah it was that was a big deal to be
there behind the booth it's a different
experience man and so
all the love man all the success to you
i love everborn i love the art style of
the story you're telling um and i know i
know i know there's you know there's
there's been talks about maybe something
you know a game or something you know
it's coming it's coming so uh i'm
excited to see what you do brother and
acg man hey i love you bro thank you i
love you too
i love your content i love how just
untethered you are oh yeah
definitely
yeah i i just love because a lot of
times people like you you speak about
games in a way and i say like i say this
about maddie i said that about colin and
stuff as well too
the point you have about games and how
you look at them and how you analyze
them
is it's it's such a refreshing point of
view because a lot of times people have
you know you start regurgitating stuff
you start hearing the same stuff
that's not at all what you do so i love
listening to your takes so thank you
very much lord king thank you for
getting that exclusive you know giardi
jim ryan jimmy cliff
come through you know what i'm saying we
appreciate the connections that you have
to make things look great for the
podcast but not a salute man you was in
your bag today what's going on we
couldn't find people find you
uh first um i want to thank everybody
that we came through
that uh
watched the show
uh
shared it out with your friends um
i i like to explain that when we get to
15 000 subscribers we're giving away
console yes all right we're going to
tell when we get close
what that is going to be and what it's
going to entail but it's going to be
centered around that show um
describe it a month i love that time and
i love giving back to the patreons that
actually support and and everybody
that's here that support you guys
actually run the show
yeah i love the fact that acg before he
pulled up
brought some merch
to make sure addict played that yeah
yeah i did
it changed his name i loved it
yeah oh yeah and changed my name i got
to do it i thought he was gonna throw a
stone and hide his head and the whole
community came out yes
it was it was insane we had to shut it
down oh yeah yeah
it was you would have been committed
forever he has like 10 hours worth of
yeah yeah yeah absolutely so
little little known fact like when i um
when people come on the show i go and
follow them and stuff like that because
i didn't know of your stuff before right
then i knew and i'm like this guy's
funny as hell
right and i said and he's being you know
because i know curse on the show but
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah so i got a chance to watch the
content and to see you
untethered
yo but okay so your reviews come across
yeah so when your reviews came across i
said let me see what he talked about let
me
yo it was the um review for uh uh alan
wake um
i almost peed my pants i had to get up
and run to the house
i said this guy is absolutely funny as
hell thank you very much and you always
support me tweeting out or whatever
you're watching you're there you know
some people may not know that you did
but you did yeah yeah
got the eyes on baby
and you got your head to the street so i
do appreciate you coming through and for
somebody that is as big as you and and
you come down you hang out with us
so much
genuine real support one of the few
genuine content creators for sure crazy
thank you very much ever born whoa
that that statement that you said that
you know we have to be more proactive
maybe you don't see yourself making
yourself us
you know like
you're walking in your truth and you're
talking your words but you're walking
the walk yes
you know
you went to comic-con and said
you probably had the thought i can't
wait to when i'm behind that booth
mm-hmm you know you gotta you gotta
visualize it you gotta verbalize it and
then you gotta go achieve it you gotta
go get it
and these are the things that you have
to do do these affirmations every monday
i put out affirmations for people
you have to do these things you have to
train your mind to do better to be
better to be stronger
usually can i tell you something real
quick about that
at comic con i did all of this it was my
dream to be there i get there
i'm all like you know um
balls deep into right never going doing
all of that stuff right
but i got you acg i realized i had no
idea how to sell this thing
and i'm at comic con
not knowing how to explain it to people
because i don't know if i'm giving away
spoilers i don't know what to do i'm not
a salesman
right
but you you are right in when you said
that right there just
um clicked with me because
it's like
you may not have the courage or you may
think you don't have the courage or you
think you can't do something
jump in the water and learn how to swim
every day and you get it and by the time
i got to the end of that convention
the pitch was
like i'm talking about like that because
right yeah yeah you worked it and and
that's the thing man you have to do it
just even when you're scared yeah just
do it afraid of heights that's why i
went skydiving
you and me talk
we talk we text not don't be about
anything let's be us life stuff like
that right no no no no no business yeah
just life
i really appreciate you sir
you understand like i really do
because you are our credit to everyone
that's around you
because you're bringing everyone up
and i do appreciate that because we have
so many people bringing us down
we don't need that fact we need more
view factions and less of them
i'm with it brother i'm with it man well
said look speaking of bringing people up
i just want to uh i put it in the chat
uh k asante's channel we do that show
yes every day he would have killed me if
i didn't put it in the chat yeah
put it in there try to get king santa's
mouth out
yes
you got you put it in there you put it
in the chat yeah it's a dance
check out that channel we do the gaming
circle every session yeah salute man i
love what you guys your brothers are
doing very i love kids i just shot them
out today earlier love what you guys
doing man tremendous and keep up the
good work brother really appreciate it
look tremendous show event a lot of fun
acg was oh my god so much fun this is
great also if you want to get the chats
and then we after that we had
well sure absolutely i know i'm ever
born if you got to roll i totally no i'm
good i'm good i'm here i'm here for the
duration all right cause we just got to
read we got to pay it back to the to the
realm
give me a moment let me roll this back a
little bit i got a lot of smoke for me
here it's just cold
it's off the uterus
we got spinning spitfire to be that next
iop merch line will be this motherflower
collection
don't forget to shut the front door
collection
we got now we got to put the azure pipe
there too we gotta put that there
yo why y'all stay silent when i said
that i had the
mute the cops was about i was laughing
but muted again
and we got michael patton two dollars
super chat stop single corp can't afford
azure but for one price yeah i guess
that price is you know pretty high
then we got splendiferous
super chat this is why i call lord sob
the non-believer no gravy i don't know
about this gravy this gravy thing right
okay so all right so you know what it is
c [ __ ] know what it is
this time
[Laughter]
pouring the gravy down yeah
pause urban ninja five dollars
microsoft ruined their relationships
with japanese devs with that true
fantasy live online deal almost 20 years
ago whole thing went down bad i think it
was more than that but i mean
then we got face
23 even twenty dollars of attack this
sega microsoft deal is is a strategic
partnership it's about azure and what it
can do for gaming anyone claiming any
exclusive games are coming to xbox out
of this clearly didn't read the press
[Music]
thank you thank you then we have mr
irishman two pounds
saab your knees are gone when p6
launches on game
that was my soccer count this is
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
if anything it may mean that sega cloud
arcade stuff may be coming into xbox
like acg said
i would love that you give me dreamcast
on expo man oh man
con con artistic five dollars chat
forget espn roundtable discussions y'all
need your own tv network outside of just
youtube
then we got italian clowns ten dollars
in the club chat blessings sega said
they want the library in the cloud like
xbox has xcloud maybe some sega stuff or
atlas could come into xcloud also love
seeing acg on and everborn this morning
i need king analogies
then we got italian clowns again father
never been against the king all hail the
king
thank you so much
you're seeing the alliance i got him
just play the tape
time y'all gonna start again we don't
need that one bad mother five dollars of
attack sega betting their life savings
and putting their house deed up to make
the super game microsoft holding that d
there is more to this
we shall see
and we got royal boyle bob
what's good lords here to always show my
support thank you brother mm-hmm
absolutely we got face once again 20
super chat why are xbox guys making a
big deal about playstation pc who cares
it's old games when or if sony does day
and date then bragging
it's old games
got to keep the boot on the neck as you
know
then we have mass erect wow two dollars
super chat
five shogen shout out to the guests
respect results absolutely
then we have uh
cheney five dollars great show lords
king dropping prophecies when do we see
sarah of phil on ilp hey we're trying
richard yeah yeah
dude exactly that was gonna come after
she announced the sega
acquisitions to bring home that would be
crazy
if sarah comes on to announce to say
listen and she gonna take her shades off
for sale
real quick and i'm not gonna take just
five seconds
phil has his generals out there sarah's
gonna bring home sega
daryl gallagher is gonna bring home
crystal dynamics okay and and and and
matt is gonna bring home wb games we're
gonna oh we're going for the trifecta
generals is out there you've got some
out there you got them in the streets
totally then we got matt jimenez
five dollar super chat anyone going to
be at anime nyc the following week would
love to meet one of the lords there i
will be there i don't even know about
you all right we got lord lord ever born
will be there for sure then we got
donald taku five dollars from jack
persona 3's color scheme was blue ps4
was yellow ps5 was red and persona 6's
will be green and you're going to see
that
it's a luther
this is what i talk about when i say
inferring thing
[Laughter]
reaching
down so we good yeah we're good
electromagnetics y'all this is a fun
show crazy love but hilarious got more
stuff popping what i'm gonna do y'all
i'm gonna put again everborn his
kickstarter is up hit that and we're
gonna hit him with that promo anybody
got anything else before we get out of
here
we good
all right so here's the promo y'all to
do everboy saga check that out make sure
y'all support and we will see y'all next
week peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right we back we gotta read one more
scrub nurse five dollar super chats up
to the lords in the chat love you guys
chris in the chat thank you sir love you
as well sir peace
[Music]
[Music]
you